e
all right the time being
1010 we will get
[Music]
started and I will open the public
hearing on um HB
1563 we we will call Representative uh
fellows to um introduce the
bill morning thank you Mr
chair because this bill
deals probably more with education
funding than with the taxation part I'm
going to begin with um some information
about the Statewide property tax and how
that is used for school funding just so
you get a back background of that
um you and there's a good description of
how it works in this handout that I that
I gave to everybody it's a two-page
document prepared by reaching higher the
date on it is 20 19 so its description
of the school funding formula re refers
to a stabilization Grant the formula has
changed a little bit since then but in
terms of the principle of understanding
how the Statewide property tax is used
for Education funding Remains the
Same so 25 years ago the Supreme Court
ruled that the state need needed to
significantly increase f funding to
school districts the state quickly put
together a new funding plan that on
paper showed a significant increase in
state funding part of that increase was
simply taking each
Town's property tax assessment for
schools and breaking it into two
pieces one piece remained the local
property tax and the new piece was
labeled state educ ation property
tax the total property taxation for
schools did not
change no new Revenue was raised from
property tax because the sum of those
two pieces was the same as the original
amount swep has been simply a mechanism
to reduce the amount of real money the
state must send to school districts swep
exist only on
paper actual money doesn't CH change
hands and it's been referred to as a
virtual tax a phantom tax and smok and
mirrors
so this is why I introduced the bill for
two reasons for several reasons one has
to do with
transparency since the money doesn't
really come to the state or uh come flow
into the state flow out of the state
because it's was and continues to be
state it continues to be local property
tax
um repealing the state property
tax uh adds transparency to the
situation and the way that I do it with
this bill is revenue neutral it has no
impact on the state aid to
schools the other consideration is that
given
that let's
see another consideration is the school
funding lawsuit that has already had a
lower Court ruling that says the state
needs to increase funding to education
and it's being appealed to the Supreme
Court but there's a reasonably good
chance that the state will have to
increase school funding and when this
happens I hope that it does not
include increasing the burden on
property
taxpayers uh repealing the swept tax
would Ure
that so my purpose in filing this bill
is that political subdivisions of the
state are responsible for raising most
of the revenue needed to Sure ensure an
environment that allows residents to
live safe healthy productive lives
servic is essential to this Duty include
police police and fire protection
maintenance of local
roads disaster and emergency
response criminal
prosecutions jail
welfare homeless shelters County nursing
homes Clean Water waste management and
more subdivisions of the state have
limited options on how to raise revenue
as you know they um political
subdivisions can only do what the state
gives them authority to
do and because of that uh political
subdivision
rely primarily on the local property tax
to fund all of these
Services
therefore uh this bill gives the
political
subdivision the exclusive right to tax
property uh there is an ex the exclusion
of two
taxes uh the railroad tax and the
utility tax because those properties
can't be
evaluated in the same manner that's used
to
evaluate regular um buildings real
estate and uh home homes and businesses
that sort of
thing so by repealing the Statewide
property tax which is what this bill
does it will prevent the state from
increasing the rate of the Statewide
property tax enforcing the property
taxpayers to pay even a greater share of
what it costs to operate the local
schools compared to other states New
Hampshire Property Owners pay the
highest percentage of costs for K12
education they pay 70% of the
cost the federal government pays about
10 and the state pays
20 if if the prop Statewide property tax
increases what will happen is property
taxes will pay even a higher
percent
so have to excuse me I
have a little bit of
laryngitis so I can go over the sections
of the
bill you see in section one is that
exclusion for the railroad and the
utilities that I told you
about I'm going to skip down to section
4 um the repeal date the date to repeal
it is December
2024 which means that the change would
occur on the November 2025 property tax
bills they would not see the swept
tax
um what I would expect to see except for
those little places that have no student
at
all some of them don't even have any
population what it this really is not
going to have any impact on um the tax
bills it won't make their tax bill go up
or down what will happen is the two the
local what what is now the local and the
state line will just be merged together
in one line because for all places
except for those really tiny
ones what they pay for schools is more
than what the state gives them in
either credit from the swep or in a
grant and let's
see so that's a um that's when that is
repealed
section section the second part of
section four that has to do with the low
and moderate income
what will happen with that is the they
will be able to apply for the last Grant
will be um a rebate from their November
2024 Property Tax Bill and they apply
for
that in
2025 so the expir date allows for time
for that program to um
finish
so even though the Statewide property
tax is really only on paper it's just an
accounting it's just a a
phantom tax it
does have an impact on school
funding because that Statewide property
tax is used as an element in the school
funding
formula the formula um which is it it's
explained um in this handout
too the formula determines what is the
cost of an adequate education for the
students in a particular
district and then it
subtracts from that amount that the
state owes the state owes the adequate
education for the students that live in
that
District to pay that to the
towns first thing that happens is the
formula subtracts the swep that they see
on their property tax bill and then it
gives the the municipalities a grant
which is equal to the difference and
that's called a grant that's money that
really
goes back to the it goes to the school
district um and is a credit for um the
municip ality which in the case of a
co-op there are multiple municipalities
in school
district so what I do in this bill is I
take that swep amount which for many
years has
been $363 million
Statewide and I freeze it in the
adequacy aid formula
so excuse
me so it's still used the fan this the
adequacy formula it doesn't change those
numbers are still in
there
if you could just read the
rest
line
21 through 28 of this
bill are not really
related to the repeal of swep at
all um it makes a
correction that it corrects a problem in
hb2 that
deleted a paragraph that allows the
department of educas to send grants to
small school
districts that's kind of
housekeeping that is also in another
bill I discovered it when I was drafting
this
one so are there any
questions do you want to answer any
questions
uh representative PL yes thank you for
taking my question I understand that
you're just essentially doing a way you
swept but keeping the obligation there
did you find it did you uh include any
kind of alternate tax to co cover that
363 million the the whole the whole
point of this is
that there is there there there is no
cost to the
state
no new Revenue to the state because that
Revenue was only on paper to begin
with I know it's an odd concept because
you're used to taxes but it's been like
this for 20 more than 20 years follow up
follow up then you're saying it goes
back to the way it was it's all from the
local property
taxpayer it go yeah I I think I think I
think that's what you're asking it goes
back to be just like like it was before
they created the swep almost 25 years
ago representative
Aly yes uh isn't the main difference
that the um so-called donor communities
will be off the hook
uh because every town will be uh
completely in charge of its own own tax
rate but it does doesn't as you say it
doesn't affect all of the towns that we
and all the other places that are dying
under really high property taxes will
also be donor towns um uh yes so so if I
can yeah can I can just address now that
I have a little bit of a voice coming
back
on back side of what I was just reading
oh did I is an example of what happens
if the Statewide property tax is
doubled I didn't I didn't get that one
oh maybe because I'm not in my own seat
oh that's because you're oh you're
sitting in the seat that I thought was
going to be vacant that's why yeah
it's right I she's trying to avoid I
want to avoid getting coal for this
weekend yeah so the like the
first
the two the two
columns are what it looks
like for two different
bium so to get the point you you we can
just look at the First
Column the this is a this is a scenario
that would say what what if the state
had to had to have this is not a
proposed
it's just a an
illustration what if the state had to
raise the base cost per pupil from the
$4,100 it is now up to$
6,000 and then thought that maybe a good
way to pay for that would be just to
double the Statewide property
tax what this shows you is
that given the thinking from 2 5 years
ago it says look the state is
paying
um let's
see what with the current base per pupil
the state is
paying
um
which oh okay the the the first line the
adequacy state like right now the state
is pay con calculates its cost of an
adequate education to be $810
million if the if the base cost goes up
to $6,000 the cost of adequacy would be
$1.1
billion double A Statewide property tax
and what happens the real money that
goes to towns which is the line that
says total grants goes
down that's because the property tax
payers are going to be covering that
whole
increase so this that's what this bill
this bill is intended to prevent that
from
happening it does it in a re Revenue
neutral
way a followup followup well the problem
that I could you put the microphone a
little bit
closer my hearing a is in my pocketbook
oh my uh the problem opinion on
something so that can be done but they
don't have to give their
opinion what I do
know is that on a scenario like this if
increased funding is
being if increased Aid
school is being funded by increasing the
property tax rate to some extent you're
not helping property taxpayers at all in
school funding and property taxpayers
those two issues go
together essentially the same
thing any other
questions yes representative
Ames trying to get this really
close for your sake um so if uh swept
goes
away it the obligation to raise that
money goes away too and there's no
obligation at the local level to raise
money to
replace the the reduction is that
true so I I I wouldn't say I wouldn't uh
say the swep goes
away I'd say swep on does not appear on
the property tax bill because what has
been swept for 25 years is going to go
back into the line with local property
tax which is where it was before swep
was created but and then and then that's
like swept on the property tax side
swept in the school funding formula is
staying there the numbers are being
frozen in there and used in this so the
calculation of the actual grants doesn't
change at
all okay well that's another question
then excuse me follow up yeah
um you've got numbers in
there very each
town and
um they're there without any formula as
far as I can see so so essentially we're
stuck into as the years go by unless the
legislature changes those
amounts with the amounts that were
identified excuse me I'm trying to
finish my
question the numbers identified there
will continue on they they're derived
from from a year or two ago and um have
no footing in a formula they're just
filling a gap um and
so what what's your
formula so the numbers that are in there
you're right they're from like three
years ago they're based on equalized
valuation 3 years
ago what is sign ific is not so much
what the number is but that just each
town is a percentage of that
363 for 20 for 20 years the 363 million
total has not
Chang if you wanted you could update
those equalized
valuations and distributed them
proportion you could you could take
$363
million and distribute it proportionally
to all the municipalities based on their
equalized valuation which is exactly
that what's in there now you could redo
that every single year it would be
essentially the same
thing representative spillsbury
thank you Mr chairman I'm going to have
to read all this much more carefully
afterwards and be sure I've digested it
but unless I misunderstanding this this
isn't actually a repeal of the $363
million obligation it's just a shifting
it's uh kind of a relabeling it's it's
striking me as more like a truth and
advertising Bill we want to make it
clear that it's still the taxpayer
through the municipal assessment that
has to raise the money but it does
nothing to alleviate the uh burden on
the real tax real property
taxpayer I would be very much in favor
of a repeal of swept but that doesn't
seem to be what this bill is so I I I I
agree with everything you
say it's
not it's
not it's not repeal
repealing it's not
repealing well I don't it's not
repealing really doesn't repeal a tax
because the tax does isn't really there
it was always the local property tax
anyway so it is truth in advertising so
so my my characterization of a a it's a
truth and advertising Bill isn't it
really it's a labeling well it is that
it is that but the second thing it is is
it
stops the possibility of expanding it
and putting even more of the burden onto
the property
taxpayers and and also I mean it's
Revenue neutral made it Revenue neutral
for a reason because I didn't want to
get in like well how how are you going
to replace it with something
else just to recapitulate what you said
I think what this comes down to is it's
motivated to
prevent an increase in the swept
obligation from the 363 it is now is
that what's driving the bill yes thank
you yes representative ORS thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative for
taking my question so I definitely agree
with what representative Aly said
earlier about this would take some of
the towns off the hook that have the
money to donate and put into the
schools uh I'm also in favor of either
keeping swep or eliminating it depending
on how this would work out I also
believe in funding the schools properly
are you in favor well let me rephrase
the
question student enrollment is going
down yet the cost per student in a
multi-district I I went through the
swept presentation that Doug Hall was
there and John and I forget the young
man Zachary I think yes and they had
some great points but student enrollment
is down the cost is going up it's in the
multi school districts
14k it's we know it's somewhere around
19 to 21k in most schools per student
cost per
student what do you proposed to level
this out in terms of it's not
sustainable to keep raising the price to
cost per student so is there a way in
your package in your idea or can this be
amended to somehow cap the cost per
student and get all these towns the
towns that don't pay in to pay
in so right now there are no towns that
are pay are paying in for um way back 20
years
ago there for maybe two years there were
some towns that gave part of
the part of the swept back to the
state that was highly unpopular and the
legislature stopped
it excuse
me followup follow up just not in I'm
I'm taking she's taking a break I'm
sorry oh
okay and keep in mind we're going to
have to we're going to have a work
session on this as well a as for your
the thought
that one thing to remember is that there
no one thing to remember is the current
cost of adequacy and what the state pays
does not come close to what it costs to
operate the
schools and then hand out it tells you
that the state property taxpayers are
paying 70% of what it costs to operate
the schools and no other state expects
property taxpayers to pay that
amount State needs to step up to its
obligation and the towns that were the
so-called donor
towns those towns that that money that
you're ask suggesting they might send
back is money that they are using to
operate their
schools because the adequate cost is
we're saying cost of adequacy that's the
state's idea of cost of adequacy that's
not the true cost of what it costs to
operate the
schools follow thank you so uh I
absolutely agree that this needs to be
fixed and I think that we all need to
get get together and and fix
this the one thing I I need to point out
is and I want to see if you agree with
me the co the rising cost of education
is not sustainable do you agree with
that I I'm not here to talk about that
this bill is about Statewide property
tax and you it would be good there are
plenty of school funding
bills that that it would be appropriate
for you to to to suggest how to change a
formula to deal with that or how to
change what the state does in terms of
at the Department of Education um to
address that issue okay thank you so I
would I would request follow up thank
you followup I would just request you
talk to Doug Hall Zachary or John who
did the swep presentation I gave them
the answer on how to fix this so I won't
go through it here but if you talk to
them hopefully they they reprentative is
there a question there yeah so uh would
you please do that are you willing to do
that I I've heard all of their their
talk and they're not and they're not
proposing I so I believe what you're
thinking about is this
suggestion that some of the
towns that have high
property tax bases return money to the
state
the amount if they had done that like
this year would be something like $29
million that is a drop in the bucket of
what it costs to run
schools representative Aly U just two
points of clarification which um one of
them is I think what you said is that
the towns could decide to merge the on
their education rate with the local
property tax contribution and just have
one line as it used to be on the
ballot
um but then other towns would be not
doing that
which no if if this bill
passes
beginning with um the
2025 tax
bills what would happen is what it it
wouldn't be that they could choose it's
that's would be what would happen Okay
because they'd still re need to the same
amount of
money and they just have one line to put
it on and and um I think at the bottom
of one of my handout it says
that I can
do I need an amendment to deal with
towns that have property tax
caps it just and that will just need to
say that when tax caps they look at the
tax rate one year and it can only go up
so
much when they do that for
2025 they have have to add together the
24 swep and local and compare that
number to what they
propose could I just have the second one
here on this this is something that
escaped me if you what what you're
saying is that the um percentage of the
equalized uh annual valuation for each
town in F y 11 when they set the tax
rate at the swept tax rate at
363 million uh with the intention of
doing what they did which is reduce it
to less and less of the cost of
Education um that
that
2011 equalized annual valuation is still
being used so that the towns that have
grown their number of children are
getting less per student than the towns
that are have been losing
population
um no uh for just for the
record that
363 was established in 20
2005 not 2011 I don't know I've heard
that repeated that's not
correct
but all that three $363 million that's
used in the formula all every year
is
just it's just using all it does is it
just reduces the amount of actual money
the state has to send to the school
districts I'm not I don't I don't really
understand maybe I don't understand what
your question was are they
recalculating uh the
annual equal equal annualized um
valuation yeah every year as I assumed
they
were and I can't quite remember now that
I'm thinking about it whether it was so
this is how this is this is how the swep
amount is determined for each
municipality you take the equalized
valuation for the whole
state and look at each municipality and
said say their equalized valuation is
what percent of the whole state if it's
1% of the whole state then their swep is
1% of 363 million is that does that
answer your question yes thank
you
okay thank you am I finished what's that
you finished unless there's other
questions thank
you Department of
Revenue um next up we have the uh
Department
Dr have we seen him before
I know do you know his name he's gonna
introduce
himself good morning Mr chair members of
the committee first of all I believe the
request to speak had two names of
Revenue counsil excuse me could you pull
the microphone closer to you well on
it's been she's got a cold we've got a
problem
got
some okay sure I appreciate that could
you give us your name certainly uh my
name is Bruce canu I'm the
supervisor the municipal Bureau at
Department of
Revenue and I'm happy to wait till the
uh wife arrives we'll we'll wait a
second because it's hard to hear sure
to
WIP
SM can't move these
things can can we move these
things here he
comes digital expression in the in your
mind
no it's on it's
on I just wiped all right remind me to
wipe again while I'm leaving let's start
from the beginning again if you'd
introduce
yourself my name is Bruce canu I'm the
supervisor of the municipal Bureau at
Department of Revenue uh the team I work
with uh helps calculate for the
commissioner the property tax rates
including uh the swept
rate um I as I was saying I think there
were two names uh Revenue Council Wong
was going to speak as well but had to
attend some other um meeting or hearing
so I will uh handle what questions and
and so forth that I can and uh defer
anything else back to to
him um the department um spoke with the
the sponsor representative fellows uh
prior to this hearing we had
identified at least one technical issue
as we read the bill uh the repeal of
rsa's 763 and
768 on December 1st of this year
2024 um would effectively
eliminate what would have normally been
uh the preparation of the swept warrant
out to the
municipalities for use in
2025 uh that being said without a
warrant to collect what is the swept tax
in
2025 we then identified something I
believe representative fellows may end
up addressing uh with uh an amendment
which is currently and most of the state
of New New Hampshire uses semiannual
property tax billing so there is a first
bill issued payable July 1st I think
every most people here are familiar with
that by law RSA
76 col
15-a and
15-a uh those
bills utilize one half of the respective
24 tax
rates this is implemented in the
responsibility of the
municipalities as as the taxing
Authority if you will and collecting
agent that would be a a bit of a
conundrum if we do not produce a 2025
set of warrants out to the
municipalities for a swept
tax the municipalities would be faced
with trying to comply with the law to
utilize last year's swept
rate in
2025 with no warrant ultimately to
collect any swept taxes in 2025 so those
two sections of Statute would probably
need to be amended to eliminate that
possibility I should have stated the
obvious which is that the department
takes no position on the bill
um I as as an aside I just wanted to
clarify something that uh representative
Aly had just spoken to a few minute just
a couple minutes ago um one I will
confirm that it was the
legislation in 2005 is when the $363
million figure was placed into the
statute and has remained that way
since um also the sequence of events
that lead to the um apportionment of
that 363 million that becomes the
warrants to each of the 259
municipalities is accomplished in the
following way um at during the fall of
2022 uh I'll use the most recent example
every municipality is reporting to the
Department of Revenue a summary of its
locally assessed values that report's
referred to as the
ms1 um we utilize that the summary
numbers from that report in the
production of the tax rates in the fall
of
2022 uh after those reports are approved
a process begins by our Equalization
Bureau and takes until May of
2023 to complete so in May of 2023 we
now now have the equalized property
values of all 259
municipalities when you sum them up you
have the equalized value of 2022 for the
entire
State we common siize that so that
starting with aworth we know exactly out
to I believe 15 decimal places what
percentage of the states
um equalized valuation is attributable
to
aworth and we derive that percentage and
then apply it to the 363
million dollar or in the case of swept
the legislature has given us authority
to have a swept rate out to a half penny
it's very unusual looking for that state
rate that's so that we can guarantee
that the tax rate the swept tax rate for
the state will call for at least 363
million it will always be over that and
that's how we end up with the dollar
amounts that would be on the warrants
that would go to each of the
municipalities the
warrants were created in September of
last
year we do that early we have until
December 15th per the statute that gu
um U the commissioner of
Dr however the Department of Education
each year needs the swept number by
November 1st pursuant to another Statute
in the education chapter so we um derive
and produce them earlier so that those
numbers are available for for education
so right now um in the municipalities
they have have received the
warrant you know effective April 1 of
this this year they're they're ordered
to collect the dollar amount in swept
taxes there was a lot of background to
the conundrum I I um
identified with the bill as written is
that we would not be producing
2025 swept warrants if this if this bill
has written became
law thank you that was uh very helpful
to understand um do we have any
questions representative spillsbury um
thank you Bruce as usual very careful
clear um explanations and I appreciate
that so if if I'm understanding this
technical issue is a one-time
transitional issue
yes it it would it would leave in place
most of those two statutes so that the
municipalities would in continue to do
what they do take one half of the TW in
this case the 2024 tax rates but it
would identify the need to
disregard the the last what would be the
last swept rate you'd see it on the
bills of this fall um just so that they
don't face that problem of trying to
obey a law that would well would create
a problem for
them represent
elme thank you uh this is something
different we haven't discussed before
the uh removal of the low and moderate
proper property tax relief program on
your division must be the ones that
administer that yes um representative
Aly no um I wish um Revenue Council was
here uh Kean was prepared to talk about
that section of the bill the municipal
Bureau itself really has no involvement
with L and moderate a as a bureau so I'm
Ill prepared to talk about that do you
do you know who
does um
I I want to say that the equalization
Bureau had some input on that but I'm
not clear on that I think that um I'm
happy to uh tell Keen that we need to
get you an answer or if there are if
there's going to be a work session on
the bill that would be good because this
program has been suffering from lack of
use since it was started and there were
attempts long ago um to try to get the
Dr when uh commissioner Platos was still
there to try to get uh the Dr to
um talk with the municipalities or
language that we could put into the law
to the municipalities to say you have to
provide these indicators in the tax bill
um so that uh people would know that the
program existed that and whether they
could use it or
not uh and since the swept is so low it
a lot of people aren't using it at this
point but it'd be interesting to
knowen to it so your question is can we
get can we get clarity Clarity from Keen
or okay someone all right that's
administering it that'd be great and and
we will obviously take this up in a work
session any other
questions seeing none thank you sir
you're welcome
just give me a moment to wipe down for
the sake of the
next is there anyone else who'd like to
testify on this bill 15 HP
1563 seeing none I will close the public
hearing on HP
you okay we will open the public hearing
on
HB
1558 and I'll first call up
representative Cole to introduce the
bill good morning Mr chairman good
morning committee how are you
all this is uh HP 1558 just a couple
small
changes uh we're talking about the agent
fee so this is when the hunter goes or a
fisherman goes to a store and they want
to get a license from the state of New
Hampshire they charge a dollar for the
agent fee for doing the the paperwork
and
whatnot it only used to take a pen to
write a a
license today you need internet you have
to have paper
cartridges the expenses
have increased
significantly so we want to give more
money to the stores writing the fees
that's what that
does any questions about that part of it
it's pretty straightforward yeah a PL
yeah we talking small money but uh is
there any basis for the $3 or is it just
out of the air the basis has always been
it's always been a dollar for writing it
and fishing game always provided a book
and they would write the license out of
a book today you have to go on the
internet so you have to have internet
for your store you have to have a
printer for your store you have to have
a computer for your store there's
legitimate expenses and it's been this
way I've been in New Hampshire my whole
life I'm 52 it's always been a dollar
since I've hunted so it's a long time
it's been that way for an awful long
time okay you you you want to continue
sure the second part was requested by
chairman Spain of fishing game there was
some concern at the way stations of
overcharging hunters for weighing game
so he wanted to establish set
amounts he was here earlier but you ran
a little long in your
last uh bill so he didn't get to testify
he will be back down if you have any
questions for him but again that pretty
straightforward does anybody have any
questions about that portion of it
yeah yes repres thank you uh doesn't
this incentivize the hunters to not
weigh
in but instead skip the weighing in
process and thereby save themselves 10
bucks no because I think the concern is
if it's an out ofate Hunter and say they
get a deer some of the stations would
charge them maybe $50 for weighing the
deer which is just not in it's not
appropriate it's really protecting the
consumer I don't think this is anything
that's discouraging it so this is
actually cutting down what they may Char
cor this is this is stopping that
behavior from happening by setting these
limits thank you so I know you need the
statistics from that I'd like to just
ask you a question
um these these rates can these rates be
set by The Fishing Game Commission or
are these in statute and and these would
be in Statute in the RS no I know these
would be in statute but right now can
fishing game set it to whatever it wants
to be or how does that work no not no
not in that instance there's there's no
law setting the fees for weighing at
this time that's why fishing game
chairman had asked me to add it to this
bill I see okay representative PL yes
I'm looking up the bill again I I'm
looking up the bill again but I remember
language that if they don't use the
waste Station they don't have to pay
that's correct so why would they not AR
they use required to use the waste
Station no they're not required to but
those that do some of have been taken
advantage of and this is to stop that
hey what do they do weigh the deer
themselves and just report it they don't
no they would just check in the deer not
weigh it at all
okay yes representative Ellery uh just
to follow up on representative pletz and
and your response it's been my
experience that certain stations will
charge you for the scale use
and never use the scale
use but you're being charged for it
because you went there oh to register
the
animal this would eliminate that
particular type of consumer abuse is
that correct that would eliminate that
behavior yes it
would representa Aly thank you uh just
for the people that don't know much
about hunting uh could you
explain on the kinds of Statistics that
you need to collect from the way
stations to look at the health of the
deer population anytime
you get a deer in New Hampshire you have
to bring it to a way station so it can
be checked in and tagged that's more of
the biology tracking for fishing game
department so they're required to do it
anyways but they're not required to
weigh the deer that's usually for the
sportsmen they want to know what kind of
size animal they
got okay thank you very much all right
thank
you NE oh I guess representative Spain
is not here so he will not be next to to
speak um and I have uh Kathy
labante
hopefully I pronounced that
correctly good morning I am Kathy leonti
from the New Hampshire fishing game
department I serve as chief of the
business Division and I oversee
licensing for the Department New
Hampshire fishing game opposes this bill
and I'd like to provide a few reasons as
to
why this in the end could be a
significant fee increase to the end user
that $1 fee is per license type on the
multiform so if
a consumer goes into a uh brick and
mortar agent and they purchase a hunting
license they also want a muzzle loader
an archery and various other typ types
it's $1 per type if you multiply that
say he buys six licenses that now goes
up to $18 in agent fees that he's paying
for that agent rather than the
$6 in addition to that we per we um do
about 60% of our licenses are purchased
online our online vendor charges the end
user the credit card fee
so the higher the amount that the
consumer is purchasing the higher that
credit card fee will be so that's
twofold price increase for the end
user as I said we we have about 60% of
our licenses are sold online and that is
increasing at a rate every year so the
biggest bang I guess you could say for
the agent fee would be our online vendor
they currently earn approximately over
$200,000 per year in agent fees from
online sales this would increase their
fees to over
$600,000 for selling licenses online so
the brick and mortar agent while we
absolutely need them and we respect what
they do this is not a big income earner
for them it really would uh benefit our
online
vendor that type of programmatic change
for the fishing game department would
cost us at an estimate between 50 and
$100,000 to implement it's programming
changes working with doit working with
our online vendor all of our
Publications and printing
cost and that as I said that estimate is
approximately $50 to
$100,000 one additional impact of this
bill is it has an effective date of July
1st our licenses are sold on a calendar
year basis so therefore we would not be
able to implement this until a January
1st and we would need a
considerable time ahead in order to
implement it with all of the
programmatic Chang
changes at the end of the bill as far as
the increase to the registration
stations this is in rule it's not part
of an RSA fishing game does not require
the weight of a game animal with the
exception of a turkey when they are
registered thank you any questions do we
have any questions
representative
Aly thank you we just heard that a
number of the stations are weighing
stations are uh abusing this in two ways
one of them by charging very high fees
for weighing and the other one for by
including a weighing fee in the
registration fee even when the person is
not weighing so do you do anything about
this
I cannot speak to that because that is
not something that we regulate we
regulate the registration stations you
have to register your animal which is
also available online you do not even
have to go to a brick and mortar agent
anymore to register a deer or a bear
that can be done
online and I have a question so um we
heard that or I think guess you just
said it there's no also there's no
requirement to weigh a deer so if
somebody goes to a weigh station and
they don't like the
price they could just say okay I'm not
gonna not going to weigh it that is
correct representative Platt yes I asked
representative Cole what the cost to the
vendor is is it going from one to three
is there any cost basis for that $3 I
didn't get a clear answer m do you have
any idea what the actual cost is and
should it go up from a
dollar well as I said we oppose the
legisl proposed legislation and it would
depend upon the
vendor um they do have to have a printer
and ink and cartridges because they sell
online but I am not an expert in what
the cost of that would
be yeah representa shamur thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question when they come to get the deer
tagged is there a charge for that or is
that already included in their license
it's $5 to register a deer a deer but
when they follow
up when they come to the station to have
a tagged after they've killed it m there
is there a fee or no fee or no there is
no fee okay thank
you yes represent
ORS thank you Mr chair and thanks for
taking my question but there would be a
fee for the turkey right because they do
have to weigh the turkey or could they
weigh it at home they do have to weigh
weigh a turkey that is the only game
animal that has to be weighed thank
you okay seeing no more questions thank
you thank
you that's all I have for pink cards is
there anyone else who would like to
testify on hb1
1558 seeing none I'll close the public
hearing on hb1
1558 we'll now open the hearing on
hb514 and do we have someone to
introduce the bill represent of
Bickford okay not seeing anyone uh can
we have somebody from okay
representative shamberg will introduce
the
bill representative Tom shamberg subbing
for representative Bickford House Bill
1514 relative to excess funds paid to
municipalities for the use of school
districts this bill requires
municipalities to remit any excess
Statewide education property tax to the
state for deposit in the general
fund thank you for your kind attention
will you take
questions only if I sponsored this bill
no problem thank you repres
shamberg all right
um let's see I do have
um I do have the Dr here if uh people do
do people have
questions for Dr well I think I think it
would make sense to come
up
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is Keen main Wong tax
policy council with the
Dr again uh this is Bruce can supervisor
of the municipal Bureau at Department of
Revenue um I just uh want to make a
point of clarification um in if you have
noticed that in the um in the fiscal
note provided at the back of the bill
the uh LBA noted that this uh proposed
legislation would have no uh Revenue
increase to the state uh but has a uh
State reduction in state expenditure by
the $29 million of the excess swept uh
in when we the Dr Was preparing the
fiscal note our take on that was uh
actually uh we noted that potentially
could be a an increase in state revenue
and the reason why we stated that it was
an increase in state revenue was because
the 363 million has already been
initially been uh recognized as a state
income um state revenue uh when the uh
swep bill is issued for the 363 million
and then with the uh excess swep being
without the excess swep being remitted
back to the state now with this bill
having the excess swep being remitted to
the state uh our thinking is that
potentially that $ 29 or $26
million um would then be an additional
cash flow um that is in the into the
education trust fund um whether that is
um in you know that's the reasoning for
for our um explanation that's the
explanation for our um our fiscal note
comment however um whether that is the
actual accounting process I am not too
sure and that probably potentially could
be something that be CL clarified with
the LBA
okay questions representative
llee thank you thank you for taking my
question
um can you walk me through um the
current practice so I'm thank you for
including the list of uh
municipalities in the financial note I'm
looking for example at Waterville Valley
um 504
4,231 so this
is money
that um
currently doesn't actually come to the
state can you walk me through how it
currently
Works um so I will try um that that
table at the back that's actually
provided by the LBA um I'm not sure um
the source for that information but LBA
probably can provide that
essentially um so this table I believe
is showing the amount the municipalities
that has um soal access swept um that
is in addition to uh what they
are ma' yes
please um for very specific questions
representative I would probably defer to
someone from education
but because we work so closely with them
I think I can handle the general
framework um under current conditions
Department of Revenue is going to go
first in this process as I described in
that earlier Bill and we're going to
create uh the amounts that ultimately
would be the swept warrants to a
municipality let's just leave it at that
a
municipality we're going to give those
amounts to the Department of Education
because they need them in order to help
them with the calculation of adequacy
Aid and during that
calculation they will be able to see
whether the amount of the dollar amount
of swept that will be raised for a in a
municipality is greater or less than the
calculated adequacy a amount of which
the details I know only enough to be
dangerous definitely ask education about
how that happens but it's right there
and I believe that's probably what's
behind the LBA estimates is that
difference so if the swept amount that
we calculated for a
municipality let's just say it's a
million dollars if the total adequacy
Aid is greater than
that
then the swept will be raised on that
tax and and turned over to that school
district and the adequacy aid will flow
to the school district pursuant to the
other
laws I believe it's when the two numbers
are um in a different order that that
the swept is greater dollar amount is
greater than the derived adequacy Aid
total you end up that difference is the
quote
excess
you
may I'm here for 10 minutes less than 10
minutes you just arrived back thank you
but you can it off
sorry thank you um so I have a
followup I followed you thank you for
your slow and careful explanation so
that I could understand so if the total
adequacy is less
and there's
excess um to the tune of let's say
million
dollars um what does that mean what
happens um uh so I live in Manchester so
we receive money from the state in the
form of adequacy right so um help me
understand the if if your town generates
more money than you need what happens
under current law the swept amount
uh will be raised through the local tax
billing process through your swept rate
that dollar amount will be turned over
to the local school
district now the the
accounting uh Keen understands better
the state accounting I don't think about
it that way um it's not part of our work
in calculating the rates but the actual
tax is raised locally it's collected
locally and is then in it so many words
it's forwarded to the school district so
it isn't an excess amount under the
current framework it's it's you can see
the number that's why you have that
list but it's not well this bill would
change that in effect right right so may
Mr chair may I have a followup sure
thank you um so let's say this number
were a million dollars so um in a
municipality where there's excess of a
million dollars they forward it to the
school
district their their own school district
and so their school district just spends
an extra1 million or $5 million or is
that return to the property taxpayers in
that town it doesn't come to the state
of New
Hampshire it stays with the town because
it's just a number that's written down
it's not money that actually flows to
the state and then get sent back to the
town yeah from the perspective of
the
municipality and the taxpayers of that
municipality those are real tax dollars
being collected and then forwarded to
the school district okay in terms of the
relationship between
the swept
amount and the local
school taxes to be raised and hence the
local school rate they pursuant to
statute we before we set the local
school rate have to account for the fact
that that swept
amount is going to that district and it
functions as if it was an additional
non-property tax revenue so the swept
amount um is real cash moving to the
school district in that one perspective
but from the tax rate perspective the
swept tax
dollars are functioning to add to the
other local school district revenues
thus reducing the amount of local school
district taxes
needed I know I don't I don't think I
get
it well so this let me can I ask one
more question follow up yeah sorry I'm
going to ask the question different L um
so I know how so I see Waterville Valley
and I just pick on them because I happen
to know a number probably not from last
year of what they spent per pupil and I
know what Manchester spends per pupil so
in Manchester let's say we spend
$113,000 per pupil I know in Waterville
Valley it's $36,000 per pupil so I'm
trying to understand if that let's call
it 20 some thousand difference yeah
is that where that money is coming from
or is it more complicated than
that when it comes to the choice of of
uh appropriating monies and spending I I
I can't speak to that but I think I have
a framework that might help um the hole
even right now most school districts
most municipalities are ending their
budget preparation process bringing
budgets getting ready to take them out
to the
voters when you think of it that way the
budget any budget really has two pieces
the Appropriations what do you want to
spend and the estimate of offsetting
revenues net those two and you have a
first estimate as to the taxes or other
funding sources necessary to pay for the
Appropriations think of it that way
swept is a funding source up against the
local school district it's going to
function that way adequacy Aid is a
funding source supporting the
appropriations of the
district and what's happening is because
swept is a separate tax but being turned
over to the school
district it's reducing the local school
district
taxes if you think of that just
Appropriations minus non-property tax
revenues gives you the initial taxes now
reduce that by the adequacy aid dollars
coming in and reduce it by the swept
dollars coming
in and now we have the taxes that need
to be raised on the local school
district tax rate that's the that's the
relationship between the two in real
terms the swept taxes being collected
and is being turned over to the school
district as are the local school
district tax dollars they look a little
fungible but you can think of them
separately but they are moving from
taxpayers through the municipality to
the school district thank you very much
you're welcome thank you any other
questions thank you very
much representative bigford we um we've
introduced the bill in your absence um
do members have questions for
representative
Bickford or have a question or maybe um
if you'd like to give us a synopsis of
the
bill
okay half and
half
and
uh and uh representative shamberg when
you get a chance later I'll need you to
fill out a pink card being the
introducer of the bill and uh
representative Bickford when you get a
chance later fill out a pink card please
okay
great that's fine no you could hand it
to represent shamber as comes
across
he answered most of our
questions just kidding just
kidding my name is uh represent David
Beckford from new dorham I also
represent
Middleton this bill uh should
be uh considered a response to this
Supreme Court decision of uh Steven Rand
versus the state of New Hampshire which
ruled that the
swept uh way it's administrated
Statewide education property tax is uh
unconstitutional to to do it in the
fashion we're doing it so we need to
change the law otherwise the court has
the right and ability to make the
decision for us and uh we changed the
swept in 200 uh
11 and if you
look under the paper I passed out to you
um two at 258
co7 now this was in 2011 it was HB 337
it changes the statute to allow excess
Statewide education property tax known
as swept funds funds over and above what
the district was
allowed uh from swept
to be left with the towns to use as they
wished and that was done by striking out
you'll see in the middle on the n on
Roman two they Str it was stricken out
in 2011 right there that's all it took
to uh now the excess funds to be used by
the towns wherever um but it was
supposed to be and originally was
intended to go to all of it to school
district it's it's really the same as a
Roman meals tax the state collects it
but in this case case they leave some of
it with the town say you can keep all of
you can keep a portion of this much x
amount of dollars but you don't need uh
say like a very rich town that has lake
front
property um they're not going to leave
it with the town because like Roman's
tax they owe it to the state it's not a
town tax it's a state
tax and so um it used to be collected by
Dr and then it' be uh distributed to the
other towns in an equitable fashion so
everybody got a fair amount and so what
I'm suggesting with this bill is just go
back to the old system I believe it was
Fred Bonte and uh Senator sapareto that
brought it Forward back when we were
doing the you uh well it was 90 97 I
think that we had the clamont decisions
we had to make changes and we came up
with the Statewide property taxes one of
those things we could use and and not
Institute a um income tax so again I'm
suggesting we go back
to where we changed it because it's
unconstitutional the way it
is
um yeah the the the decision also says
it states that such funds must be used
for the exclusive purpose of satisfying
the state's adequacy Aid
obligations and uh now
so that's what this bill does now
there's a little extra wording in it
than what there was before and the
fellow that did the bill says well
there's been some changes over at Dr I
think and but this takes us back there
to to where we used to be before it was
unconstitutional um I should let me look
see if I get another note
here um just for it
uh information there's another bill over
in education that's very similar to this
so I recommend you folks take a look at
that I don't understand why there's two
different Bills going to two different
uh committees doing pretty much the same
thing the only one I could see the only
thing I could see in that bill was they
said and you really really cannot do
this and send the money back to towns
you know for towns to use it for them
okay that
I think that's pretty much all I have
for
you hope that's very
convincing thank you um you have a
question do you have a question yeah
representative
alme thank you
um how can you send education money back
to the general fund inste how can you
send money back to the educ the general
fund that came from the education trust
fund
well I'm the wrong guy to ask that I I I
asked Ben the same thing the fellow that
did this his name is Ben and I called
him up a couple times I said why is it
being done this way why not the
simplistic way we had in 11 and he said
it was because of the changes other
changes in the law eventually it gets
over to the trust fund is is and he said
if you wanted he'd be happy to come here
and
explain is is follow Ben in the drafting
yes okay he's the one that drafted the
Bill thank you so we had a few
conversations with the same thing I wish
I could I told myself I'm never going to
be able to repeat this well so he said
he would come here and talk to you if
you wanted the other option uh
representative may be to get him to put
a statement together and you could
submit it to the
committee could be
lengthy but yeah if we don't understand
it it's going to be harder
to Yes uh representative fellows um yes
I have a question about the fact that
your bill says the municipal
takes the money that it collects from
swep and sends it back to the state
so okay in in my town and as far as I
know in every town not everybody pays
their tax bill um sometimes they don't
pay it at all sometimes they don't pay
it on time Y how how are so the money
coming back
in how is that going to work that sounds
pretty complicated sometimes they pay it
late well the way the system is set up
the towns are responsible for collecting
the money and if they don't collect the
money as you pointed out they take out a
tax anticipation note they have to
borrow the money then they're given the
authority to confiscate property after I
think two years and a day to be able to
cover their uh cost of does does that
answer your question so I I think so so
so that means that every town is going
to have to probably well they they might
not have to borrow it they might have
funds available but they're going to
have to send money to the state that
they didn't
collect yeah and and it probably means
that would you think that for the past
20 years they've been sending all of
whatever the total swept amount is to
the school districts but of course there
have been cases when people don't pay
their taxes and so the towns never
really collect all that
amount only since 2011 when the law was
changed it was I think it was an
amendment maybe a floor Amendment it was
repr of Hess as I recall that uh
submitted
it
um and then we went to uh letting towns
use
the um anything over and above what they
would need in other words they they get
their portion that's enough to fund the
school at the rate that was
determined but because they have so much
profit in town There's an additional
amount well that money is supposed to go
back to I'm going to say Dr and they're
going to redistribute it I think it's a
complicated way to do it if I had my way
I'd have the state collect all the money
into one pool like we do with room and
meals tax and then they redistribute it
gasoline tax these are all state taxes
but it confuses people when goes to the
town like that and you're right Town's
the ones that's got to cover the uh what
doesn't come in and we used to be able
to in my town New Durham cover the whole
thing you know with uh money in the
general fund but now we've been uh
borrowing to to cover you know we have
it's a little expensive right now too so
that goes against the
taxpayers okay representative ORS and
followed by repres in elberger thank you
Mr chair and thanks for taking my
question so prior to
2011 would you and I realize you're
talking for Ben a little bit here would
you and Ben agree that the swep system
worked and it was the change in 2011
that allowed towns to as you just said
withhold paying into swept some towns
and and therefore it's kind of messed up
the system messed it up so it's
unconstitutional now but did follow up
follow up so but prior to 2011 did the
swept system work as yes the answer yes
it did it it works so well I think we
should go to it and and abolish the
local tax I think we should have the
schools be paid for by the state um
that's what the Supreme Court has told
us
clamont both clamont decisions are that
way uh what's the word and they cherish
the word cherish was interpreted to mean
fun
and so that's that's a way to do it we
don't want to go to a sales tax and an
income tax well we're stuck with a
property tax so everybody gets
um uh taxed equitably throughout the
state that was the gway
decision and uh and then distributed to
the schools as uh the Department of
Education probably is the one that would
make the
decision representative
elberger thank you Mr chairman your
comment just now leaves me trying to
figure out what my question is so let me
try this the swep tax at this point is
basically a local property tax that this
I'm sorry functionally okay functionally
I'm not talking legally but functionally
it's a local property tax that the state
claims as being its
contribution to local education is that
a reasonable descript destion it's
applied to every locality but it's a
state tax it's it's just like we have
our County tax okay oh I'm sorry thank
you it's can't see
you it's it's not a local tax the sweat
what we pay on our tax bills it's just
like having a county bill that's a
county tax had nothing to do with the
town the only thing the town has to do
with is collecting the money your tax
collector takes the money and then it
gets distributed just like anything else
um your county tax a St going have to
cut a tech for at a certain time I think
it's December really tight if you ever
get a chance to change things it makes
it very tight for the towns to get that
check out to them because they're still
collecting money in but you see it's a
state tax just like R and meals so
therefore there's no right to have the
excess money from it belongs to the
schools followup Mr chair followup thank
you it's
officially a state tax yes
it's based on local property values so
when I pay my tax bill and it says my
Municipal tax my my property tax list
Municipal tax and County tax and swept
tax MH it's all coming out of my
property bill it's not a tax the same
way that business taxes go into the
general fund and then get spent from
there right the state business yeah they
don't they don't pull it the same way
right the collection is the same but the
pulling the pooling and distribution is
different so my yes thank you my
question is as someone else
asked if there is excess why would the
excess go into the general fund rather
than back to property
taxpayers who have been
um be there there's a uh decision on how
much money each Town needs now someone
like
clamont um doesn't have much
money over there someone like in
wolfboro say with a right beside the the
lake there has a lot of property from
people that come from wherever other
countries even and put up palaces on the
edge of the lake well because it's a
state tax that money belongs to the
state not to the town
none of it belongs to the town that the
only thing town has is
collection no repr thank you
representative house and came back now
it's officially in that status and uh it
provides it it approaches this problem
in a different way it is entirely an
agreement with your position that this
is a state
tax um and it provides
for the remittance by the M municipality
that still collects the money entirely
to the
state to the education trust fund to the
Dr and then into the education trust
fund um and fee this bill also allows 3%
for the mun municipalities to keep as a
processing fee and then then they send
the balance so I that's a bill in this
Committee in U education there's a broad
school funding bill that has within it
swept reform that has the same
Provisions so my question to you that's
background is whether you would
consider um I'm not asking you Pro or
con right now but this is an alternative
that seeks to resolve the Constitutional
issue but in a different way and it
avoids the uh difficulties that may
arise in the timing of the determination
of just what is excess swept and so
forth it just all goes into the general
fund into the education trust fund um so
um I'm wondering how you would react to
that proposal as in contrast to
yours uh that might be fine I'd have to
look a little more closely but it's
certainly in the right direction and uh
my
I I put this bill in because I had a
pretty good feeling that this Rand
decision was going to come out in as
being unconstitutional what we changed
in 11 it wasn't unconstitutional before
that it became unconstitutional there
and I'm saying all we got to do is uh go
back to what we did and we'll be
constitutional and we don't have to
worry about the court coming in and
taking over for us um they don't want to
do it and we've done it and I felt we
were fairly successful in the past
you know some of my editorials have been
I would go beyond like this gentleman I
spoke to about so this is just go back
to go back to the
beginning but uh thank you um this is a
u well this whole thing is a very
complex issue in general and we know
through court cases and uh constant
striving to come to a good decision here
um we'll take this up in a work session
um does anyone else have a final
question yes representative
fellows yes so on the fiscal note Dr
says that this amount that that could
could
be the high the high end that could be
going back to the to the state is 29
million um frankly I think it I think
less than 29 million would be collected
but no do you I don't think anybody pays
all their taxes on time so they wouldn't
get the whole amount about but but my
point being 29 million is compared to
the $3 billion do that is being spent on
on public education that is
1% do you think this is really going to
make a big
impact yes I think it'll make an impact
that's why we did it
you know we we needed another source of
income uh back I don't know who who can
remember uh
uh Susan Aly she she would remember when
we had I don't know what you're talking
about oh you don't
no I'm talking about when we we first
did this you've been here since
forever I I hope do it and we we
instituted this back when Fred banti was
planning running for governor he he
didn't make it but this is platform of
his and you remember Frank
sapareto and they pushed very much and
said well okay we're not going to do
this property tax I mean excuse me
income tax not going to do sales tax you
know we had Governor Shaheen that wanted
a sales tax but she didn't want an
income tax um so anyway the the
compromise was to okay we're already
using property tax anyway so if we do it
from the state that'll satisfy the con
the Claymont decision that says it the
word cherishing it which means we have
to
fund
so um you got to do
something this is a this is a simple and
easy way out because that's what we did
before any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much representative thank you thank you
very
much I don't have any other pink cards
on uh
HB
1514 is there anyone else that' like to
testify on
this oh question well it's just a
comment to to the committee uh both uh
representative spillsbury and I
I are um on a special subcommittee of
the education committee and looking
at school funding bills they include
house
bill
1856 I believe it is I got that
1486 no not 14 directly addresses swept
in a different way yes in 1586
representative Lun no bill very
confusing because 1486
1586 incorporates much of uh
representative Ames bill that's
currently an interim study so we have
four bills oh wait a minute there's a
third Bill uh which is the next number
up um 1686 yeah which is sponsored by
I'm sorry I missed when I said 14 I
meant 16 you're co-sponsoring on that
one yes I'm a co-sponsor that
bill um takes excess swept like this
bill and moves it to the state but I
just I I I ra raise this just because I
think everybody should be aware of we
got several different ways of
approaching this and right now in two
different policy committees which is
most unfortunate and then we've got in
our committee this interim study bill
which is my Prime sponsored bill um
somehow we're going to have to pull all
this stuff together but uh yes I just
this background music for everybody
thank you representative Ames and I I
think uh yeah this is and this is why my
previous comment that there's there's a
lot going on here and and we're going to
need to uh take this into advisement and
and uh into a work session can just add
yes representative Ames just said
exactly what I was going to say I just
wanted to add that when the special
subcommittee on education funding meets
on FR on Friday for a work session we'll
make sure that they know about the two
bills that are ways and means great
sounds good thank you very
much all right I'm going to close the
public hearing HP
okay that's mine for introducing oh okay
was gonna say wait a
minute
okay we should ask that anybody who has
a pink card there it
yet
yes
anybody who what
oh maybe okay I didn't know all these
were here yeah all
right get a
lot
okay I'm going to open the uh public
hearing on HB
1484 um let me first say before
introducing the uh before we introduce
the bill um I have a lot of pink cards
here I see a lot of you are passionate
on this one way or the other and if
there's uh me if there are people here
who know each other and feel comfortable
coming up to the the desk at the same
time and talking consolidating uh
testimony that would be helpful um so
that we can um get all the information
but not um Extended unnecessarily all
right first we'll invite up uh
representative Kelly to introduce the
bill thank you chairman and thank you to
the committee for allowing me to speak
today I am representative aan Kelly
representing Berlin Carol Jefferson and
Whitefield many of you may have heard uh
recently about a situation in Northern
Coos I want to start by saying that this
bill is not meant to deal directly with
that issue um that situation highlighted
something that with this bill I'm
attempting to address I apologize in
advance for the length but this topic
has taken me six months to digest and I
still feel I'm only seeing the top of
the
iceberg I assume many of you can
sympathize with now having to boil that
down into a 15-minute speech you can
digest
today first we need to grasp the idea of
an emissions reduction ton in ER often
referred to colloquially as carbon
credits and er represents the equivalent
of removing one metric ton of carbon
dioxide from our atmosphere it's a
standard unit adopted by financial
markets much like we talk about oil
production and trade in terms of barrels
when it's often when it often never
actually ends up in a barrel anymore
what an ER looks like in real life can
vary it helps to break the system into
two categories the regulated compliance
market and the voluntary Market
compliance markets are systems imposed
by governments these are often referred
to as cap and trade programs every
business in a state or a country is
given a yearly cap on their emissions if
they're above that cap they can lower
their own emissions or pay other
businesses to offset their emissions in
the latter case they would purchase
erts each year the cap is lowered and so
demand for erts Rises and with so so
does the
value California has the only regulated
market here in the US but there are many
other markets around the world incl
including Europe and South Korea it's
important to note that none of these
markets are uh are limited to their own
geographic region the voluntary Market
is much more complex and harder to grasp
due to the rising import importance of
ESG metrics investors have placed
increasing Demand on large corporations
to prove their ability to recognize how
their own emissions are affecting our
climate for many large companies like
Delta or Exxon Mobile this has meant
voluntarily funding projects that
purport to fight climate change they do
this through the purchase of erts this
has led to a whole new industry of
carbon Traders working in dozens of
different exchanges with hundreds of
project developers marketers private
regulators and certification authorities
I don't have the time today to describe
the complexity of this network I would
point you to an article in Bloomberg
last month titled Wall Street gets ready
to cash in on1 trillion climate Market
the article describes how the world's
largest banks Goldman Sachs City Group
JP Morgan and Barclays have all
established dedicated carbon trading
desks in the last three years in
response to the rapid growth in this
voluntary carbon
market so how do we get from carbon
credits to current use while erts come
in dozens of forms from landfill gas
Reclamation to solar Farms 80% of all
credit sold on the California Market as
an example are classified as Forest
carbon credits these Forest credits fall
into three types aforestation credits
where you are protecting land that is
under threat of complete deforestation
reforestation credits where you are
planting a new Forest on deforested land
and improved Forest management or ifm
credits where current forestry practices
are altered to improve carbon retention
these ifm credits represent 84% of all
carbon credits sold on the California
Market the reason they are so ubiquitous
is that they are comparatively cheap to
produce lack the regulatory burden of
other projects and they rely on
measurements already done in industrial
forestry
operations as domestic industrial Timber
production has waned over the last three
decades we have seen institutional
investors like hedge funds and private
Equity become the owners of large tracks
of land all over the US in a 2001 study
bemoaning this development the New
Hampshire based Forest Society stated
the longterm implications of this shift
are not yet understood while many of
these institutional investors have
largely continued traditional forestry
practices I believe the Boom in Forest
carbon credits shows us exactly what the
long-term implications will
be that 2001 study shows us how domestic
Timber production in New Hampshire is
specifically threatened by a booming
Forest carbon Market industrial
Timberland accounted for only 10% of New
Hampshire land but accounted for the
majority majority of harvested logs a
2021 study from the New Hampshire Farm
Bureau found that 82% of people who
gener generated revenue from current
used Forest land owned more than 100
acres these owners represent only 8% of
land owners in New Hampshire but they
own over 95% of the remaining Forest
land if only a few of these large land
owners chose to switch from traditional
forestry to carbon credit production it
would mean the end of Timber production
in this state just this year the
decision of a single large landowner to
do just that was a key factor in a
month-long shutdown at New Hampshire's
largest sawmill we cannot afford to not
act on this issue otherwise those jobs
in an entire way of life will be lost
forever there are many issues like
carbon credits that the state many
issues with carbon credits that the
state needs to resolve I have a separate
bill before another committee to replace
the timber tax that would be lost from
adoption of Timber of carbon credit
programs as I testified and as we heard
last week from many of the people who
will testify against this bill today
that is going to be a very complex
process we agree on that point there is
no single metric that we can just point
to and say you owe the town 10% of that
there is currently no state or federal
mechanism for tracking all Forest carbon
contracts those contracts can vary in
length from one year to hundreds of
years the value of a credit will vary
wildly based on hundreds of factors
including the market in which it's sold
none of which are based here in New
Hampshire any ask any person testifying
today what a single ER is worth and
you'll be hard pressed to get a straight
answer we don't even have an estimate
for how many credits were generated on
New Hampshire Forest land last year not
even an estimate the first timber tax
took land lawmakers six years to pass
and it even passed only by a single vote
I expect a new Timber tax will take us
years to properly
craft this bill you have today is my
simple solution it is meant as a
placeholder until we have a new
mechanism in place that makes towns
whole all it simply does is says that
land generating er no longer qualifies
as Forest land under current use this is
completely fair and I think by reading
of RSA 79a that should already be the
case the RSA defines Forest land as land
growing as determined as land growing
trees as determined and classified by
criteria developed by the state Forester
and adopted by the board the intention
of that definition is further explained
by the definition of unproductive land
which says it is land incapable of
producing agriculture or Forest Products
or where the location of which renders
it inaccessible or impractical for the
harvesting of Agriculture or Forest
Products Forest land was never meant to
exist under current use without the
harvesting of trees that is even more
clear when you see the methods for the
conservation easements were established
by the same piece of legislation in
1973 the current use board sets the
rates for White Pine and hardwood forest
Land Based on the idea that a 10% Timber
tax will be paid to town in lie of the
yearly property taxes they lose through
current use land that is not paying that
tax should not qualify for a subsidy
from other local
taxpayers what I'm asking and what what
I wish was laid out better in this bill
is that we the legislature should make
clear the to the current use board that
this activity is wholly separate from
traditional Forest practices we should
give them the opportunity to hold public
hearings with those parties interested
in in selling carbon credits and set a
new rate based on the loss of Timber
taxes we have many other questions to
answer about carbon credits and while we
do while we cannot allow while we do we
cannot allow our forest land to be
locked up for hundreds of years by
speculators and others on Wall Street
looking to make a quick return for
investors we cannot afford to wait for
another year you will likely hear from
many today who are opposed to this
solution I would ask you to please ask
them to elaborate on why I agree that
current use has worked well in this
state but we're talking about a paradigm
shifting event event that risks changing
the very premise the program is based on
the trees will continue to grow as the
current used board does their works and
once we have the proper guard rails in
place they will be able to sell the
exact same number of credits they would
have otherwise thank you again for the
time I apologize uh for the length and
I'm happy to take any
questions thank you uh representative PL
do believe I wrote down every word
verbatim I don't think you would do you
have that testimony the final testimony
to the through the portal to and I'll
email it directly to you all thank you
representative shamber thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative taking
this question uh so what will be the
effect on the amount of dollars that can
be put into a a conservation funds of
these
towns uh when the land use or the
current use
changes yeah and I understand the bill
itself as it was written and it was a a
tough time to get this LSR through um I
I believe should have said it will also
create a new category under current use
for this generated property so that that
way they they aren't losing out they
aren't being forced to change in
fact it could exist under the forest
land designation alongside hardwood and
white pine and other a specific fee for
carbon credit generation which wouldn't
change the land
use
thank you I wasn't quite following that
one because I was thinking about my own
question but which is perhaps
related but uh if we imposed this and
all um Forest land in uh current use
which is being used for tax credits at
this point um became uh fully taxable
under our property
taxes wouldn't we end up with a lot less
Forest before you finished passing your
other
bill yeah so I again I would recommend
that this be that there be an amendment
put in place to specifically give
current the current use board the
ability to reclassify or to create a new
designation for carbon credits I think
that that's vital to to to exactly what
you're talking about um I think that the
the the I we have no idea exactly how
many acres in the state are under carbon
credits there's no way to measure that
there's no because there's all these
voluntary markets there's no single
place that we can go to and say you know
where are the credits being generated in
New Hampshire at the same time we can go
to the Bureau of uh forest and lands and
ask them specifically how many logs were
taken from New Hampshire Forest last
year we have all those statistics
because we require them by law we don't
require that for carbon credits at this
time so we have no way to develop a
framework we have no way to even begin
the discussion about what they should be
what they should be paying towns because
we don't have those numbers so my my my
intention you know first of all I would
have I would be hardpressed to ask towns
to find out who's generating carbon
credits in their in their area like we
don't know as a state the local towns
with the especially in the in the small
areas where current use is much more
prevalent it's going to be very
difficult to for that one assessor who
might only work a few days a week to go
out and dig through journals and dig
through other places to find out who's
generating carbon Credit in their area
so um I I I don't think uh those who are
generating them currently are going to
go out of their way to divulge that
information um voluntarily so how would
you would they find out who is on
generating these credits um my
homeowners
association has 34 Acres of forest
behind it uh and because of the fact
that it was required in the subdivision
and also that it's very Steep and wet uh
you wouldn't be able to build on it
anyway but we did do a cut 30 years ago
but the cut that we did recently was to
get rid of 90-year-old Pines that were
totally useless for anything and
therefore cost us quite a bit of money
to make sure the houses didn't get
destroyed so um how you wouldn't be able
to do it by how much they how often
they're taking the trees
out they may be saving the up for the
purposes of having a 50-year-old tree
that is in Prime condition to
sell how would you how would you be able
to find out there were uh they had a
carbon credit contract I appreciate the
question thank you the I I so the other
bill that I have working in in resources
and Recreation development I'm what I'm
asking in that bill is that we begin the
disclosure process so much like we have
an intent to cut that's filed uh right
now currently I'm asking that an intent
to generate be created um starting this
year next year um that would begin to
divulge that information so that we are
more clear on the situation
um the uh with without the additional
framework around a tax without the
additional framework around a Timber tax
I also want to caution against the um
the the focus on smaller plots um the 34
Acres you're talking about the the the
effect on the forest industry is is
minor um when we look at the what is
currently going on on those plots of
land majority of uh New Hampshire
current use owners are in that 10 10
acre to 25 acre 10 acre to 100 Acre
category the majority of owners are in
there but the majority of land is in
that much larger category where we talk
about institutional investors owning
huge huge tracks of formerly formerly
paper company and Lumber Company land um
that is now still being used for
industrial Timber production um that's
where the risk to the industry really
lies um the the currently California and
many other exchanges require 100 Acre
parcel to be uh to generate a carbon
credit and the that requirement is to
take care of any of the the smaller uh
fluctuations that could happen around
the edges of a of a smaller parcel um so
that 100 Acre limit is already focusing
in on those those larger parcels and
that's where the the the chance for
these investors that's why they're
looking for those
Parcels follow up yes uh behind our land
uh there is 150 acres of forest and
Wetland that um I I am on my
Conservation Commission and we spent
$500,000 of our our saved money to um
join with the local Land Trust which is
the
owner would they have
to to um go out of current use so thank
you again for the question because there
is not going to be cutting I believe the
the when when current use was
established in 1973 79a was was
established alongside of 79b and 79d
which established the the rules for
easements it was also established along
with 4477 45 the definition for an e a
private easement um all of those were
were set apart that they set them aside
so that nonprofit and and non uh and
then uh locally owned properties they
are not currently under that current use
designation um or if they the the there
they have a wholly separate section of
law to deal with them um I think that
it's very interesting that the
disclosures required by for 7745 which
require the uh any encumbrance on the
property be transmitted on the deed and
be transmitted to the registry of deeds
is I don't believe is currently being
done by the majority of people
generating carbon credits in the state
of New Hampshire that's an incumbrance
on the property it's a 100-year contract
that could last forever that's another
one of those questions that we as a
state need to address and if we allow
institutional investors to come in in
the next 12 months and really take
advantage of a booming Market we risk
losing control of the
situation representative PL I don't
understand at all how can you the land
is there the trees are there so you you
sign a contract for a carbon credit so
trees were already there and so how is
this increase anything uh to me it's
paricle but but maybe you can give me a
feedback on that what's it do does it uh
doesn't allow cutting eventually it has
to be cut or it falls down so so what
what is new here so I I agree it's
considered an alternative investment
vehicle um which by its definition is a
vehicle which is an investment that by
its own has no real value so yes I agree
with you that it is very difficult to
wrap your head around why we would pay
and Es specifically why we would pay
areas where there was already
conservation going on New Hampshire has
over 50% of the State 53% of the State
is in in current use that doesn't count
the conservation land that work the
White Mountain National Forest uh the
state parks that we have that all work
alongside the current use program to
give us the 84% Forest cover that we
have in the state which has been 84%
since 1949 when the original Timber tax
was passed so to me this is a way to
monetize something and to get a quick
buck and to get people to pay you for
something that requires the less people
on the ground it requires less
investment and as it was described in
last week's committee less of the
Chainsaw swingers and more of the techie
guys um so that's that's my issue with
it yes representative
Bolton thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question but I know like
Main and New Hampshire are the most
forested States and the Union why would
someone go to something that's probably
like um less of an investment to get um
carbon credit monies versus making it a
wood lot and harvesting Timber so thank
you um I think specifically in New
Hampshire that's why we're here in New
Hampshire um we have one of the as it
was described by the uh by nhtoa one of
the simplest and best current use
programs in the country uh it's simple
it doesn't require the other uh
requirements from Vermont or Maine and
we give a massive amount of money
towards it um and for what it's worth it
was a huge success it's been a huge
success you know I live in Berlin I live
I grew up in Randolph I surrounded by
current use land and I loved being part
of the forest um and I wouldn't have had
that opportunity probably without the
current use rules that we have today um
but we you know if we look at Vermont
for example Vermont has a 25 acre
requirement we only have a 10 acre
requirement it requires a much more
robust Force management plan we only add
a Subs we only add an additional
discount if you have a forest management
plan um Vermont's uh you know the the
state of Vermont estimated that the
average median uh taxpayer in Vermont
who has land under current use saves
about
33% um and when we look at property tax
rates between New Hampshire and Vermont
we are remarkably close 1.93 versus 1.9
effective property tax rate so if a if a
uh program where the current use rates
for Forest land are double what they are
in New Hampshire so we with a forest
Steward for Forest stewardship plan um
on the high end gives 65 uh dollars per
per uh per acre uh Vermont starts at1
145 so we are looking at a you know
Vermont gives 33% I my by my estimation
just using those numbers we are looking
at close to a
66% property tax uh abatement from the
current use program compared to Maine
same type of thing so their Pro program
set up where it's a base rate off of
your tax rate so it's 10% for if you
have a forest St Ste uh stewardship plan
it's an additional 20% on top of that if
you allow Recreation on the on the um
property it's an additional F 10% if you
do some other character some other
factors in there so uh we give a great
subsidy which makes us a uh a great
Target for those looking to make money
now
thank you very much thank
you okay next up I have a card for Dan
bueron good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee I'm Dan burger
and I'm the chief of the wildlife
division at the New Hampshire fishing
game department um I note that there's a
number of other people here to speak so
I'll try and keep our our points brief
um so um our Fishing Game Commission um
sets positions on all potential
legislation um they have voted to oppose
this one of the main concerns that um
the department has with this bill um and
I I believe um I'd heard one of one of
the representatives mention this is that
um our concern is what this will do if
you remove the incentives to keep um
land in Forest land um what are the
Alternatives and and the potential to
lose land to development um by removing
um you know the the possibility of
putting it in current use um some of
these properties likely have multiple
things going on um you know sale of
carbon credits as well as as active
forestry um obviously that will vary
depending on the size of the lot um and
and the the drivers of the property
owner um um but again we we feel um the
current language here um has the
potential to remove a fair portion of
land from forest Land by removing the
incentive um and we have a concern about
that we would much prefer standing
Forest whether it's mature um or young
um versus developed
land thank you any
questions saying none thank you oh I'm
sorry tell me your name and Dan beron
from um New Hampshire fishing game
department
okay thank
you okay thank you thank
you um next is Robert
Johnson sure sure
do I have H cards for them as well or
okay
introduce thank you Mr chair members of
the committee for the record Rob Johnson
representing the New Hampshire Farm
Bureau as a federation's policy director
no program is more important to work I'm
sorry could you
introduce sorry well you could introduce
me I'm Jason stock executive director of
the New Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association good good morning afternoon
actually no program is more important to
working farms and Forest in the state
than current use and as the bill sponsor
acknowledged the program works current
use Is An Open Space
Program Forest land used for an
emissions Reduction Program is still
open space Forest Land We oppose the
current use program being used for other
public policy objectives other than open
space assessment as the bill does know
that Farmland can also be used to
generate carbon
credits want to touch on one thing that
was also mentioned by the sponsor that
current use is not a subsidy program it
is simply an assessment of land at its
current use
value please recommend the bill as itl
thank
you again uh Jason stock New Hampshire
Timberland owner ERS Association and I
to have come today before you to speak
in opposition to the bill as Rob said
it's open space law there's two criteria
to get into current
use obviously open space undeveloped and
greater than 10 acres and as the prior
one of the prior sponsors mentioned the
Simplicity of our law makes it the Envy
in many other states when it comes to
open space it doesn't become encumbered
with other public policy issues concerns
that can change with administrations and
and change with the political winds and
this level of stability has made our law
very very secure and very
effective I also want to point out
that land enrolled in carbon
programs can be cut and is harvested
harvesting does occur on these
properties it's not an All or Nothing
proposition so I see some I see some
some some some grimaces so and there are
others that can speak to the
technicalities but the simplest way to
put it is is that someone is purchasing
your carbon the carbon that's growing on
your property they aren't necessarily
purchasing every single stick of wood
that's growing on there you can either
subscribe to a management program that
says all right we're going to cut x% of
growth and that excess growth will then
be sold sold into a carbon program there
are way each deal is different and each
wheel each deal gets each deal gets
negotiated sales of carbon in many
respects are no different it is a it is
a asset it's like selling a conservation
easement it's like selling a development
right it's like someone coming along my
neighbor comes along and says Jason I
really love the way you maintain those
Trails on your property I'd like to pay
you X doll to continue to maintain those
Trails on your property it's the sale of
an asset or the sale a s a private
transaction between two parties on
either an asset in this case carbon or a
practice um and so I want to make sure
that folks understand that it's not an
All or Nothing proposition we as an
organization we have quite consciously
decided not to get into the debate of
whether or not carbon trading is an
effective means of of of uh mitigating
global climate change but what we do
recognize is that it is a
Marketplace car and it is a a an
opportunity for land owners to sell is
an asset that land owners can sell and
it is and it can provide in some cases
an alternative Revenue stream and these
are private transactions between two
individuals um in so with that I'll I'll
conclude my testimony I'm happy to try
to answer any questions as I have said
there are others behind me that know the
intricacies of these programs and these
markets much more deeply than I do thank
you representative PL yes you say that
uh current use simply requires open
space greater than 10 acres is there any
requirement to cut
timber great question there is not okay
so it could be yes it's the same
question it could be possible that there
is no revenue generated from current use
uh if uh at all uh because there's no
Timber cut but uh T Timber should
eventually would the land owner probably
would cut it to keep the keep keep the
forest younger shall we say great
question there is no obligation to cut
timber so I can buy buy a piece of land
and have it in current use and I can say
my personal management objectives is to
grow old growth that's what I want to do
and I can do it I can grow I can buy a
piece of Timberland en roll it in
current use and say my objectives are to
grow Upland bird hunting habitat and I
can do a lot of patch and small clear
cuts across that property because that's
my objective that's a personal decision
that the land owner
makes representative fellows um yes do
any of your members um have they sold
land to other companies so they can get
the carbon
credits I'm or and the the other part is
it does it have to be sold or can it be
leased I great question I'm aware of of
three members that have that have
entered into carbon programs they don't
sell the real estate they maintain the
real estate and in these instances they
are selling the credits similar is if
you own a piece of real estate and you
sell a development rights to someone or
you sell a right of way and so there are
I I'm aware of at least three
members um that have entered into these
I'm not aware of any kind of
transactions or pricing or anything I
just know they have mentioned to me yes
when I look at my management objectives
and I look at the carbon programs it
fits with what I want to do with my real
estate and therefore I felt comfortable
entering into this can can I just follow
up follow
up this is hard for me to understand
because it's all new so if I owned a
piece of
land somehow in I make a transaction
with whoever wants to buy these carbon
credits and they give me some
money and
could be a lot of
money and is it do they pay yearly or
you think or one time or whatever it is
they get a lot of money from it but
they've done nothing to the land but
clearly the land was worth something
because they got money for it so they
don't really seem to fit within the
intent of they don't it doesn't seem
like they should belong in the category
of current use that's the same as Forest
lands because the value is higher if if
they have or if they could sell these
credits yeah it it's it's like Jason
said earli it's not an All or Nothing
proposition they're still managing the
land and just managing it
differently I'm sort of asking yeah I'm
asking about the the I'm questioning
that if they have the opportunity to do
this then the land has greater value
than it's being taxed at because its
current
use yeah so that the land isn't first
off the land is not what is being sold
here I am selling I am selling
carbon and that continues to grow
my trees grow the land continues to be
open space and therefore qualify for
current use assessment at some point in
time and as you've heard these contracts
can vary from one year to 99 years at
some point in time the contract ends and
at that point I can cut those trees and
at that point I will pay a Timber SE a
severance tax to the to the to the local
municipality but in the the
interim I am I am I've I've done a
transaction I am selling carbon it's the
same as if I sell a right of way an
easement um I can you know these are all
acceptable transactions that can occur
on open space land and that land can
remain in current under current use
assessment as long as I don't build on
it pave it or subdivide it and sell it
so it's less than 10 acres
just to add to that you're not
necessarily making more you may be you
may not be it's been it's a it's the way
the land owner wishes their land to be
managed there are many many reasons for
that yes representative
leapley thank you um so can you talk a
little bit about how current use
benefits your members
GL gladly so our our members many of
them I would say the vast majority of
them their land is in is is assessed is
taxed and assessed under current use
assessment um this tax law is one that
as as Rob had mentioned I'm being taxed
on my ability to grow ra raspberries and
strawberries or corn and silage or to or
to grow or to grow trees um and so why
our interest in this is that this tax
policy is one that the almost I would
say almost all our members particip this
assessment Pro program is one almost all
our assessment all our members excuse me
participate
in for many current use land owners if
their properties were assessed at full
market value at ADV vorum they could not
afford to hold on to it the property and
then way it's not available for
recreational use for wildlife uh you
name it the TR it's it's key to the our
state's tourism
industry thank you may I may I have a
followup followup so um this is ways a
means
and it's our job to to figure out how to
run the state right to get income so
that we can continue to run the state so
I'm totally
value
what what is happening right like I
totally value open use totally value
Farmland but it sounds like what we're
describing is an alternative Revenue
source for people who own this land that
currently isn't being taxed so there's a
couple ways to look at that and that's
our job because we make policy um one
way is to say well you know we
don't care because we don't tax income
it's income
uh I guess my question is if we are
giving someone a tax
break because they can't otherwise
afford to do these practices that makes
sense to me but if there's another new
Revenue stream that didn't exist in the
70s that exists today it seems like it
would make sense for us to understand at
the very least what kind of
Revenue um people are able to make in
the way that they're using their land
right um so they're using their land in
a way that's generating Revenue so I'm
trying to understand um if if you have
any understanding
of how that is changing the ball game
and if you can give us some insight
there sure we're not necessarily opposed
to taxing but not not through the
current use program and Jason can
elaborate on that thank you and as you
heard earlier there's a there's another
bill it's being heard by the resources
Recreation development committee it
looks at creating a a a carbon
tax um in this case using RSA 79 which
is the state Timber tax law so it would
create that I testified on that bill
that communities can all already tax
uncut wood RSA 795 allows because this
is a local tax we're talking about RSA
795 allows a municipality to cut un or
excuse me tax uncut wood most folks
don't are unaware of it I see
representative Al criming but that's on
the books it's never been used to my
knowledge I've spoken to Folks at Dr
they have never heard of it being used
but it's on the books and well it's been
on the books since day one of the the of
the Timber tax which is going back to
the 40s and my testimony last week was
is that if you what wish to car if you
wish to assess a tax on carbon sales
there's a vehicle already in in statute
look at that vehicle and have Dr they
already have the authority have them
develop some some rules around that so A
municipality can in fact assess that
tax the mechanism's there they can do it
and so modifying current use we think is
inappropriate and even the even the the
timber tax bill we don't need it you can
already assess a tax on uncut wood in
the state of New Hampshire
municipalities need guidance and our our
our testimony
was let's let the tax and the timber tax
experts let's let them and the
biometricians and the Foresters and so
forth let's let them work on it and and
come forth with a
proposal um but just modifying current
use is not going to that's not the
that's not the solution representative
Ellery thank you yeah thank you uh thank
you for taking my question previously I
thought I heard you say that you know of
at least two or three uh contracts that
are already in
existence it is that
correct yes a followup Mr
chair
yeah
so it's John so if they're already in
existence if these contracts are already
in existence why do we need to do
anything excellent
question also I would add that this is
after kind after the
fact do they do those properties they've
entered into these contracts being
assessed under current use do they do
they now does this now retroactively go
after those properties and those land
owners I I I agree I think the
Constitution has something to say about
that but again this is this is the you
know the rabbit hole we find ourselves
wandering down with this piece of
legislation and thank you for your
question representative
ol yes representative yes uh I don't
know if there's anyone here from the
society for protection of New Hampshire
forests but if there isn't could are
okay believe they plan to speak I think
that it's important that there be some
uh description of what New Hampshire was
like in uh
1912 and uh why the current use was put
in
it I I I I wasn't here back in 1912 um
okay but the current use law the current
use law did go into effect the current
use law did go into effect and the
actually this this particular law went
into effect in this in the the late
late 60s actually and it actually
involved the Constitutional Amendment
and so forth but at the time the state
um and Rob touched on this you had
property
values um you had kind of tree farms
getting assessed as if they were house
lots
and that kind of imbalance in in that
imbalance created a problem where land
owners are facing tax bills that are in
that are being inter appropriately or
perhaps appropriately but they're being
assessed at a use that they don't that
their property isn't if I'm growing
field corn to feed my dairy cows but boy
that would be a nice house
site you see the the disparity and so
that's why current use was developed was
say all right if you're growing corn
we're going to assess you as if you're
corn ground and the other thing I I'll
mention is that when that land does get
developed let's say it gets developed
down the road there is a penalty assess
so the town does receive revenue from
from that property above and beyond the
current use assessment and then at that
point once it's developed it's taxed ADV
VOR any other
questions okay seeing none thank you
thank
you next up is Tom
Thompson
good morning uh my name is Tom Thompson
and I'd like to read my uh
testimony um this is to the
Laura sber and chair who I believe is
not here and committee members my name
is Tom Tompson representing the Thompson
Family Tree Farm located in Orford New
Hampshire also for the
record I serve on the New Hampshire
current use Advisory Board which is
attached to the Department of Revenue
Administration I'm here today to testify
in opposition of House Bill
1484 the sponsor of this bill wants to
exclude land which is in the current use
program if a landowner signs up for
carbon
credits does that mean he also wants the
landowner to pay the current use change
tax because that was not clear in in the
bill this bill is inconsistent with the
current use law as a contract for carbon
credits is not a change in the use of
open space land
law I believe house bill
18 I'm sorry
1484 is a knee-jerk reaction to a
recently new large land owner who owns
Connecticut Lake Headwaters in Northern
New Hampshire who signed up for carbon
credits while cutting back on harvesting
Timber I encourage you to kill this Bill
thank
you thank you will you take any
questions yes I will do we have any
question yes
representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
so representative Aly mentioned earlier
uh back in the early 1900s I believe New
Hampshire was mostly deforested in terms
of maybe it was 20% Woods 80% other
somebody back there shaking their head
and those so hopefully they'll tell us
what that percentage is uh my question
is if the trees are sitting there in
their in uh they're being held in what
Forest as forested land excuse me at
what point did they become a hazard I
mean trees don't stay there forever so I
mean so these trees that are being set
aside like if it's what is it 10 acres
or more do those trees eventually get
harvested so they're not creating a fire
hazard or you know if we manage the land
the animals do better you can't let the
forest always
mature otherwise it otherwise you
actually uh hurt the wildlife so I guess
I'm wondering is then how is this land
managed in most cases and I will share
with you in our case which we have we
have a we are certified tree farmers and
uh we manage it in a sustainable manner
we we uh Harvest Timber uh we protect
the water quality we enhance W life
habitat and uh allow Recreation on our
property and um
the the first question that you asked
about the back in
1912 uh those figures are fairly close
uh you remember back late 1800s uh there
were huge sheep farms all over the the
state of New Hampshire and therefore
that there was not as much Forest it has
just completely reversed now because uh
the tree farm organizations and other
land organizations in this state have
done a remarkable job in uh sustainable
forestry and and I will also point out
to you that U on those lands
uh and I'm talking about my property we
own 2600 acres in the state of New
Hampshire we open it and share it with
the general public uh we uh allow
snowmobiling uh that brings into this
state uh there's 7200 miles of
snowmobile trails across the state
uh 84% of those are are on private land
such as ours and it brings into the
state direct and indirect over $600
million every year but it doesn't stop
there we open it for uh hunting and
fishing uh uh hiking
um all types of of of foot traffic on
our property and we saw a huge increase
in all of that uh during Co and and we
enjoy uh sharing our land and and we as
land owners allowing all of that
activity on our property we don't get
one nickel from the state or the general
public and we're not asking for that
there is a insurance policy uh that the
Bureau of trails puts out uh that
protects us particularly for
snowmobiling but other than that all of
that is giving to the state and to the
public
uh we do have our land in current use um
just a word about current use uh the
reason it was developed and and came
into being back in
1968 and it had to go through the
Constitutional Amendment which is a very
high bar to to go
under U it was because the Southern Tier
of New Hampshire was being destroyed a
farms uh Open Spaces were being uh
subdivided left and right and uh
and people in in this state came
together and decided that they wanted to
protect the open land in in the state
for everyone to enjoy and it took 5
years just to get from the the very
beginning to in 1973 when that law was
signed into into law and uh it's now
over 50 years that we've had a very uh
successful current use in the state of
New Hampshire it was one of the early
ones in many states across this country
have tried to copy that uh and U it it
one of the reasons is because we've kept
it simple it's simple to for a land
owner to get involved in it uh keep in
mind that when that happens and we have
to go through a a process with the town
mapping out our property the forest
Farmland Etc uh then it the final point
is it get it's it's there is a lean on
it and it is recorded at the registry of
deeds any other
questions yes represent
Lori thank you for taking my question
thank you there's a current move that
I've heard about and seen described in
different literature or regarding air
rights above
property would this legislation or any
or similar legislation prevent someone
from taking air
rights I as you have in say New York
City where uh you have a building but
that building is here and then the the
air above
it can belong to somebody else so that
you don't have a shadow cast by a tall
building and some sort of I hope we
never get to that point yeah well so do
I but that's why I ask the only shadow
might be is because we grow big
trees well not as big as Washington but
no we don't you're right all right thank
you thank you very
much uh next is uh Stephen
wood thank you chair committee
um
push the
Buton we
go Tomy why'd you push this button um
please introduce yourself as well in the
course of it sir I'm I'm Steven Wood uh
I and my wife um own and manage poverty
Lane Orchards and fum Hill ciders in
Lebanon and planfield we and our and her
family uh own uh a combination of about,
1400 acres in Lebanon planfield and
Dublin all of which is under current use
that is eligible for current use and has
been from the get-go I'm here just to
say others have said bits of what I
would have said well
enough New Hampshire's current use law
is the best current use law in the
country and it is stood the test of time
because it was so sharply written and
because the construct of that land use
train uh change tax is so cleverly uh
construed that it it it compensates
municipalities very well for for for
land that finally comes out of current
use while it gives them sometimes they
don't notice this or agree with it but
it gives them the benefit of having land
that does not require Services doesn't
require education doesn't it is in fact
that and it's been studied over and
again to be the best thing for
municipalities uh for a taxpayer to have
lots of undeveloped land in your on your
in your town now we have we've managed
an orchard and we are also uh Timber
Farmers registered Timber
Farmers Lebanon in particular our good
Orchard land and our good hardwood land
um is hugely developable and always has
been and um we if we had to pay oh yeah
it's also open to the public in all
manner of ways and we did you including
our pick your own Orchards but also they
use our
forests um I mean I know Sue does it's
right down the road from I mean
representative Aly I'm sorry um this
would be impossible we would not have
been able to continue to own this
land unless we wanted it to develop it
if we have been obliged to pay the taxes
for What's called the highest invest use
that is the highest market value for
that land the taxes would wipe us out in
a a
year the orchard wouldn't exist the
forest wouldn't
exist please treat the New Hampshire
current use law as sacct it's worked
beautifully it should be treated like
the US Constitution or the New Testament
Cannon or something that you just don't
mess around with it and as uh Mr stock
pointed out there is a construct in
state law that can address the issue
that is largely driving this
suggestion I suggest that it is
inappropriate to mess with a law that
has served us so well for 50 years thank
you thank you um yes represen fellows so
um you have two types of land it is the
current use rate you're you're different
for the orchard versus the forest
there are there there are differences
with within them somebody who uh
actually knows the current use law as
some people do here better than I do
could better explain this but we pay
varying rates according to the uh
potential productivity of of each sort
of land so even within an orchard there
can be uh different rates according to
the soils ditto the ditto the forests uh
White Pine Land is treated differently
from hardwood land is treated
differently from Wetlands or shrub land
or open land and the current use
Advisory Board um together with Dr um
works works out what those those lines
are and what those rights will
be so so if I looked at your tax card
yep the description I would see several
different Parcels of land with a no no
you'd see one land one value of land
under current use the current use value
of the land um you would also
see the I think you would say I can't I
can't remember where they still put that
on but the the market value of the land
which is which has no bearing on the tax
we pay we pay the the tax based on the
current use value which is the value
what is construed to be the value of the
land as it is currently being used and
again it's an open SP it's whole it its
whole intent is to maintain open space
which is what it does by doing the thing
I just described to
you follow up yeah I'm
so so I'm thinking that the orchard land
must be worth more than the forest land
but you only
see one well I can they have different
rates I can go down to the to to to the
city and look at at at the various
rates that acre to my total value oh
that's exactly what I meant you have
multiple pieces that have different
values there yes I mean it's not it's
not a huge they usually they they sort
of mud things together a bit but there
but yes there there there are different
components of the value that I see on my
tax bill yes R and shamard thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr wood uh they value
your land by a Matrix system do they
not classifying the woods and
the I I I'm not sure what a matrix
system is
Sir well um it's check on it I'm sure no
I I I have um
okay there there is a there is a scheme
whereby they are obliged to apply a
range for each sort of land as described
if that is a m Matrix system
then
yes okay represent Aly just quickly on
did you know that this is the way they
were assessing land in
whatever did I know what this that was
the original way of assessing property
was by it by its uh uh by its productive
capacity or capability right
no I did not thank you for teaching me
that all right do we have any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you for the opportunity to
speak to you and for your
services you got
uh
more yes okay uh next is Charles
lavesque thank you Mr chair members of
the committee I'll try to be brief uh I
wear several hats here today I live in
antrum uh I have a natural resource
consulting firm but I also am the chair
of something called the Statewide
program of action to conserve our
environment space space is actually the
nonprofit organization that advocated
for the current use law uh back in the
1960s that led to the
1968 Constitutional Amendment allowing
the law to be passed in 1973 to have
current use so we are the current use
Coalition a number of the folks who've
already spoken here are members of our
board and so our our goal essentially is
to maintain the current use program
strong just like it is today because as
other speakers have said it works really
well and Most states in the country have
a similar program New Hampshire's works
better than any uh other in in the uh
country I won't repeat what's been said
before me but support uh all the
arguments made by those who are in
opposition to this bill as am I and the
space board uh I will say that um a
couple of points that haven't been
covered include number one that this law
is really a retro retrospective law and
if you were to pass the bill as it's
written um because current use has come
under under this in previous bills over
over the last 50 years you would have to
allow current use land owners who own
forest land out of the program because
it's retrospective they have a lean on
their property it's filed at the
registry when they sign up for current
use so essentially the way it's written
uh as we have it before us this bill
would only cover Forest land owners who
have yet to to apply for the program and
and be part of it it could not cover any
current use land owners who are already
in the program um a couple of other
points uh this is current uses not a
subsidy that term has been used and what
we need to remember is that when we had
a constitutional amendment passed on
this in ' 68 what it did in the
Constitution and in state law is it set
up a different taxing method so uh the
current use method is equally legally
valid as a an assessment me method based
on the current use of the land as is ADV
valorum which counts ENT the highest in
uh value of the property based on the on
the local zoning as a house lot as a
commercial lot so these are equally
valid you can't say one is a subsidy
over the other they they're both valid
under the Constitution and state law two
other things and then I'll end um on
Monday at 9:00 a.m. wearing a different
hat because I've been working in the
forest carbon offset world for many
years I'm going to be doing a
presentation on Forest carbon and Forest
carbon offset to the Science Tech and
energy committee at 9:00 they're going
to continue the hearing on the bill they
started last week at 10:00 but I'll be
presenting to them uh I'm sure you're
welcome to attend that but also i' offer
to you Mr chair and members of the
committee I'd be willing to give you my
PowerPoint presentation and in fact come
back here and present to you if you wish
to learn the details about forc carbon
offsets but um there have been
speculation about uh this growing in New
Hampshire the reality is that as of
today there are fewer than 10 Forest
land owners in the state of New
Hampshire uh who have carbon contracts
on their Forest land and that amounts to
just under 200,000 acres and remember
New Hampshire has just under 5 million
Acres of forest so it's di Minimus it's
it's a very small part of the landscape
and frankly it is not growing at any
large uh Pace the one property that
brought on this bill the Connecticut
Lakes property uh there's
146,00 acres under a carbon contract on
that property but since that carbon
contract was signed in 2014 we've had
less than 50,000 Acres added to carbon
contracts so it's not growing at a vast
space uh pace and it's not expected to
frankly because what landowners are paid
especially small landowners when I say
small I mean Family Force owners like
some of the folks who who spoke before
me uh it doesn't really pay them enough
to agree to sign a contract that would
be either 40 years in the voluntary
carbon Market or a 100 years in that
compliance market so uh as somebody
who's worked in this for many years I
don't expect there to be huge growth in
uh land going into carbon uh offset
contracts uh in in the next 20 years
unless something changes because the
marketplace is simply not paying them
enough to encourage a land owner to in
fact sign a contract that is very long
term and I'll end it there and thank you
uh for your time okay do we have any
questions yes representative spilburg
so um to your point about uh current use
just simply being an alternative method
of
evaluation wasn't the Advent of current
use to create a class of prot protection
so that conventional assessment
standards of highest and best use
wouldn't have to apply and current use
would dictate the valuation yeah it's a
good question I look at it slightly
differently um because current use does
not require you to keep your land in
open space forever it is a temporary
protection and really the law was set up
so that property taxes themselves didn't
force you into changing the use to a
develop use on your land so that you
could afford to keep it as forest and
farm and open space land so it really is
not a permanent because you can change
the use and when you do you pay the
change use penalty as other other folks
have spoken about but it's a good
question Riv and plat I would I would be
interested on your PowerPoint just for
general education but I don't think we
have the time to have a
presentation well if you don't mind you
could email it to Ways and Means I will
do so great thank
you okay thank you very much thank you
very
much okay we have two cards here left um
next um Patrick hacky from the dncr
division of forest and
land
give you
enough thank you Mr chairman for the
opportunity to testify on House Bill
1484 um for the record my name is
Patrick Hackley I'm the state Forester
and director for the New Hampshire
division of forest and lands I'm just
going to read from my testimony and we
can we can riff off that if you have any
questions
um so uh division of forest and lands
part of the Department of Natural and
cultural resources does not have a
position on this bill as written but we
do have a few concerns so let going to
give you a little bit of background uh
the division of forest and lands is the
state agency charged with the execution
of all matters pertaining to forestry
Forest management and Forest lands
within the jurisdiction of the state one
of our key responsibilities is to
protect our natural resources for the
benefit of the state's citizens visitors
and Forest
industry so it's our agency our division
uh that's represented on the current use
Advisory Board and we also share
enforcement duties of RSA 79 the timber
tax law we share those enforcement
duties with Department of Revenue
Administration so as has been mentioned
by a number of other um individuals who
have testified in this bill um this this
uh particular proposal is to address the
participation of landowners and carbon
credit programs that could result in the
potential loss of Timber tax revenue due
to reduced
harvesting this bill would enable towns
to exclude Forest landowners from
enrolling in the current use program if
they sell carbon credits instead of
Timber which as we've mentioned is
subject to a severance tax under SE RSA
79 forc carbon credit programs as
Charlie just mentioned are still in the
early stages it's not widespread yet it
could as representative Kelly mentioned
it could become more popular we don't
know yet it's really early right now um
but there is growing concern
particularly in the North country that
the timber tax revenue may be diminished
over time should an increasing number of
land owners particularly those large
corporate investment grade landowners
choose to generate carbon credits rather
than Harvest
Timber acknowledging this new Revenue
source to land owners and its potential
effect on the tax revenues for
municipalities I want to make the
following
points the situation in Pittsburgh which
you've heard described and which has
been in the media for the last8 months
mon or so and the state's largest
private landowner which uh we've all
acknowledged has inspired this bill and
many other carbon related bills this
this session that issue is still
unresolved under the terms of the state
held conservation easement the landowner
must submit their 10-year Forest
management plan to our agency to the
division of forest and lands dncr for
review and approval or not while the
landowner has indicated that they intend
to drop the Harvest to half the volume
of previous years in favor of generating
carbon credits the State has yet to
approve that 10-year management
plan relative to the purposes of the
easement number two at this stage it's
too early to determine how many land
owners Statewide will enroll in a carbon
credit program and how much this may
affect local tax revenues however
altering the current use program to
address a subset of land owners is not
good policy and could result in
unintended
consequences as has been mentioned by
other speakers this
afternoon uh third and last Point our
current 's tax program as you've all
heard is regarded as the Cornerstone of
conservation in our state and is a major
reason why New Hampshire's landscape is
82% forested second only to the state of
Maine at 90% excluding land owners from
current use who seek to generate
alternate Revenue sources from their
land May discourage them from keeping
forests as forests and seek other uses
that would be less beneficial and and uh
of broad value to the public interests
with that I'll conclude my testimony
thank you for the opportunity I'm happy
to take any
questions thank you do we have any
questions yes represent fellows so I I'm
uh not clear about the fact that they
haven't submitted their plan yet have
they owned this property for a long time
so they've been under current
use um or is something changing thank
you for your question representative
fellows um so the current landowner um
submitted their uh they just submitted
their plan two weeks ago actually so
it's under review by my agency and uh
other agencies right now um they
acquired the land from the previous land
owner in October of 2022 so they're
relatively new they just have owned the
land for a little over a year um we
didn't know about the change in their
plans until early summer and it was at
that time we we requested them we the
the state monitoring the conservation
needs been on this property requested
that they provide a a revised annual
operating plan which is just obviously a
one-year plan but also more importantly
a 10-year for stewardship plan and so
that we just received recently this is a
fairly large document it's you know it's
probably about 50 pages with a lot of
charts and maps and stuff so anyway it's
going to take us a little bit of time
but we will be getting back to them in
that plan though they they indicate
their Harvest levels so that's under
review
now follow
up so things like how much they plant to
harvest that will have an impact
on they're on what what does that why is
that important well again as as has been
was mentioned the introductory comments
by representative Kelly the concern is
that this particular land owner um is
proposing to to reduce their Harvest uh
by 2third actually or actually by half
50% and so that has caused a lot of
concern about the the impacts to the
municipal Timber tax revenues
particularly the town of Pittsburgh
where most of this land is located but
also those jobs related to um the
harvesting of the Timber on the property
so logging Trucking and then a third
value that comes from
the the harvest of Timber of course is
that wood supply to the local Mills in
the North country and elsewhere where
this wood is transported so there's some
economic Ripple effects that occur with
a drop of that magnitude and that's been
what's been in the newspaper and of of
broad concern for the last several
months follow up so tell me what
decisions you need to make when you
study this whole plan that they've put
together
what like what are the options can you
are you going to tell them they need to
be in a different current used category
or what
right so I can't get into the details
because I've been asked by our
department of justice who's also looking
at the conservation easement um closely
to see how they're going to respond to
this proposed drop and harvest but the
the conservation easement that um
basically um prescribes how this land is
to be managed broadly is being looked at
very closely it's a very uh
multi-layered conservation easement I
would say it's probably one of the most
complicated easements we've we've
drafted in the state so we're looking at
the easement Provisions just to try to
get it answering your question and we're
holding that up and saying is the
decrease in Harvest um in any way a
breach of the easement and that's is it
is it is is it in line with the easement
or is it not and that's that is our our
charge if you will to determine
that
okay thank thank you okay any other
questions I think we were out of
questions all right but thank you thank
you okay the last pink card I have is uh
Matt
Ley from the forest
Society
good afternoon thank you Mr chairman uh
for the record I'm Matt Ley I'm the
public policy director for the society
for the protection of New Hampshire
Forest uh we also oppose this bill for
really all the reasons you've already
heard so I won't repeat those um I would
just want to make one point and um
Charlie LEC mentioned the presentation
he's going to be giving to the Science
and Tech committee um on Monday morning
you know if you are able to tune into
that um it's excellent I've heard
Charlie present on this on the topic of
uh Force carbon management and Forest
carbon markets so these are very
complicated issues and I'm actually
still learning about them myself but um
you know it it certainly has relevance
to the bill before you um you know again
there are so many different facets that
go into this um that it's it's you know
again we think it's important to to know
that but you know but to just respond to
the uh question that representative Aly
made earlier you know New Hampshire
looks far far different today than it
did a hundred years ago and um you know
the forest Open Fields you know our
Landscapes are in part what sell New
Hampshire you know travel and tourism is
such an important part of the economics
here that open space is is a part of
that and um you know current use has
been a key to helping New Hampshire look
like it does today but I'll happily take
any questions thank you do we have any
questions representative ORS thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question so if this land instead of
being forested managed and 50% of the
less trees roughly are not going into
Lumber
production are they going to have to pay
the new owners are they going to have to
pay a tax to bring that land out of the
conservation uh setting it was in and
into this carbon tax setting uh you're
talking about the property up in
Pittsburgh yes the huge problem yeah I'm
so I actually um I can't answer that
question um I don't know what the
um you know uh you know what what they
would need to do um but like it Patrick
said the state's looking at the easen
and their and their management plan to
determine if it's in line with the
easement and Patrick was the speaker
Patrick Hackley the state Forester right
yeah okay follow up followup uh would it
be possible to bring Patrick back up to
answer that question
Patrick knows the answer does Patrick
know the
answer do we have any questions from
Matt did you have a
question I just wanted you to to
speculate Suppose there was a sale very
similar to the one that we heard about
up in Pittsburgh and their plan that
they submit is drastically different
than the existing plan because they say
we're not going to to we're only going
to harvest 10% of the Timber that we
were doing before can you tell me what
your best guess about what would happen
next is does the do they lose the
conservation do they lose a current use
Cate categorization or what
happens yeah I'm again I'm not sure I
can answer that question I I don't know
if right um
so I'm not going to speculate because
like I said it's an unresolved matter
between the state and the
landowner
um so that was a
hypothetical similar owner similar piece
of land right okay
so um conservation
easements are are widely applied and
um it's a it's a tool for Forest land
owners and conservation groups to keep
land
forested okay in con and I'm speaking
very broadly and we also have a subject
matter expert right here in Matt Ley
with the forest Society so conservation
ements often put um Provisions within
them and it's an agreement it runs in
perpetuity with the deed and it's
agreement between the land owner it's
considered the grantour of those
development rights and the grantee or
the easement
holder um so the grantee holds the
development rights in in exchange for
donating or selling those development
rights there's an obligation on the
grant tour the land owner to manage that
land in a sustainable uh manner um
typically that's that's often the the
commitment of the land owner is to
manage that land responsibly and
Provisions and and conservation
easements are all shapes and sizes and
flavors and colors so you can have a lot
of different Provisions as long as both
parties agree to those
Provisions so that's the charge of the
easement holder is to ensure that the
land owner is complying with the
provisions of the easement and if
they're not there are there is also
Provisions in that easement of how to
deal with what is considered a breach of
of of the agreement uh basically a
violation of those Provisions there's a
whole section in the easement that that
it that we hold up on the on the
Connecticut Lakes properties and there's
a provision in almost all easements that
give the easement holder the um the
process by which they um address that
perceived breach is that
helpful so that's where we're at now
with the current situation in the in the
North country is we reviewing the
provisions of the easement in the
context of their revised management plan
to determine if it's in compliance with
the spirit intent and purpose of the
easement thank you any other
questions seeing uh yes representative
sorry just a clarification is a
conservation
easement freeing the landowner
from current use taxes or from some
other because it seems like we started
talking about something new with the
conservation easement so a at a very
basic level a conservation easement is a
legal agreement between a land owner
private land owner and an entity that's
going to hold and enforce the terms of
that easement so it could be uh a land
trust like the forest Society it could
be a a town or city or actually even a
state as in the case in the Conneticut
lakes and generally um with an easement
the land owner will will give up either
sell or donate the rights the the
development rights you know so they so
they they won't you know build a
shopping center or you know roads or
whatever you know in return they will
get either paid or they get a tax break
um in some way um and the easement hold
the The reason an easement holder would
do that is to protect those important
you know ecological values you know
water quality forestry all that so it's
again it's a uh a legal
agreement may I have a followup yeah
followup so it's a separate instrument
that's correct a lot of people confuse
current use with conservation easements
not the same so they're still enrolled
in current use and the conservation
easement is a separate agreement um not
necessarily related at all
so guess another followup so the um
town could still be collecting
money under a current use
agreement or perhaps a different tax
agreement under an
easement uh I mean typically it would be
you know that current use assessment I
mean it's possible you know sometimes
there may be a payment in Le of taxes
Arrangement although that's not a
standard okay thank you very much just I
mean to picky back on that it's my
general
uh thought process that that the
conservation easement is more to stop
development in the future where you can
be under current use sell your property
they have to pay the the tax but they
can develop it whereas a conservation
easement would stop development correct
thank you all right very good thank
you is there anyone that's it for pink
cards is there anyone else uh that has
not filled out a pink yes I just had a
question if the Dr was going to come up
for this bill um I do not have a card
for them did you have a question for
them I do have a question for there's no
fiscal no okay may I still ask a
question of the
Dr um is that uh
sure
good afternoon um ke Ming Wong TX policy
council with Dr I'd also like to invite
uh our assistant director of the
municipal and property division to be up
here as well to I think this would be
more relevant in for thank you so much
for being willing to take my question
thank you Mr chair
um I've learned a lot today so forgive
my question if it's ignorant um so it
sounds like the current use Advisory
Board falls under the
Dr um so my question really
is if people are making money on um you
know selling these carbon taxes is that
filed in any way with the
Dr because it sounds like part of the
concern is that we really don't know to
what ENT this is happening in the state
um so my question is do you have a
record of these kinds of
transactions
either under current the current use or
under your role
as you know collecting like business
taxes or any other Revenue
oversight as it relates to current use
um no we wouldn't collect that type of
information
in terms of Tax Administration in
general I don't believe so but it's
certainly something we can look into um
if it if or anything would be related to
business tax but but more than likely
not in relations to business taxes if
it's like any other business
organization if it's a business
organization conducting business
activities in New Hampshire yeah it'll
they and then within the the income
threshold that gross income thr
threshold then yet the uh that the
person generating that income would be
subject to uh business tax
so if I can have a followup so if a tree
farm engages like in sells carbon tax
credits and makes money then they would
include that on their income statement
but if an individual is doing it then it
wouldn't they wouldn't file it cuz
because it's not a business
tax not necessarily if the business is
if the individual is doing it as a
business there are uh so proprietorships
okay also business uh considered as
business organizations that would need
to follow a business tax return
okay in terms of being able to aggregate
that information and get it in a format
that would be understandable we probably
don't have something like that that
would make more sense in relation to
current use in terms of if we knew the
number of properties let's say that had
current agreements or selling carbon
credits that are currently in current
use that would be really helpful I
assume um and that's not something that
that we have at the moment okay thank
you all right any anything else any
other questions okay thank you very much
thank
you okay and um I'm assuming there is
there anyone else who did not fill out a
pink card who wishes to
testify seeing none we will close the
public heing did you want to say
something looks like we are out of
questions thank you though for offering
all right I'll close the public hearing
on um hp1
1484 the next hearing the next hearing
okay all right
um given that um we are a little bit
later than we anticipated
what how
many I only have oh my God all of those
only no no I only have
one
um all right um we are going to take a
break um I didn't expect the last one to
take an hour and a half so I apologize
to the next group here will try to
um be back by two well or before to
actually could you could you come
here um come over here
please
all right let's let's take a f minute
break and
uh do I who who is here actually who is
here to speak on
1551 just you oh well then okay then
let's uh let's just get it done
you want a five
minute all right okay then
uh all right we will open open the
public hearing on hp1
1551 and um I'll
recognize the representative
um I can't read your last sorry Summers
Summers okay yep simple
enough oh yeah that would help to
yeah 1551 thank you Mr chairman thank
you for community members I'm I uh I'm
represented James Summers represent of
Rockingham District 20 down the southern
part of the state um I introduced House
Bill 1551 not only as a representative
as a uh a PhD in in uh strategic
business but also as a small business
owner um House Bill
1551 I come across to me from several of
my constituents and if you notice it's
all the sponsors are actually bipartisan
so this is actually bipartisan within
the house and a few senders that did not
get on here in time bipartisan as well
this is in to look at the at the fact
that New Hampshire after current
legislation in Texas and Tennessee um
New Hampshire is one of only two states
itself and Louisiana are the only two
states do not recognize the difference
between a C Corp and an S corp now not
to go into the the weeds of business but
when you create a business and a lot of
you business owners yourselves so you've
had llc's more than likely and a lot of
your small businesses are llc's but you
have the option of a partnership you can
do an LLP you can or you can do a escort
and then if you become a little bit
larger and you have a lot of equity then
you can become a C Corp now the
different why a person would want to
become an es Corp and why there's a lot
of demand for a lot of your llc's out
there to become es corpse becomes really
multifaceted reasons one is there's a
federal tax benefit from the IRS if you
become an escorp to be an escorp you
have to have less than 100 employees you
have to file an IRS
2553 and you have and then to be
approved by the IRS once you do that you
have to be be able to incorporate
yourself with an incorporating entity
and you have to be able to have yourself
a list of officers the es Corps are very
common in family run businesses why is
that well because a twofold one you
actually as an owner of an escorp you
can pay yourself a regular W2 wage
meaning that you pay yourself the
federal government gets their their um
federal income tax and they get their
social security and you pay as like a
regular employee as any of your other
employees do the second reason is you're
able to get as a small business equity
and that way you can put equity in your
small business into your family members
or employees that have been there for a
long time can have a part or portion of
the
business now um where llc's the owner
cannot pay himself a regular wage as you
know he has to take out what's called a
owner's e owner share or owner um where
he actually just takes a gross amount of
money however much he wants takes out
the business and he's taxed on that on
his regular taxes es Corps are taxed on
regular income taxes too so an escort
you is that taxes a corporation and then
it gets filed through on the income on
the federal on the business goes through
the taxes personally of the
owner where C Corps are completely a
complete separate entity where it's
taxed by itself and then the income of
the person is completely separate that's
a drastic a little bit of difference
between them now where this comes into
why it's important for escort and C Corp
different differentiation is is C Corps
as we know are double taxed income comes
into the corporation it's taxed then
anything that's paid to shareholders or
Equity to members is taxed again on
their individual income
tax escort because it's a small business
less than 100 employees is federally is
taxes a business and then any
distribution to the shareholder within
the escorp is not taxed again because
that escorp income was already taxed
when it went through the owner's taxes
because it's passed through the owner's
taxes federal government gets that and
that's why the federal government did
that and the other 48 of the other
states do it but New Hampshire and
Louisiana do not recognize an ESC Corp
so therefore it is taxed the individual
is taxed twice by the state of New
Hampshire the business is taxed then if
they pay Equity to the equity shers in
that small business and goes through
their personal income tax it gets taxed
again so it's they're actually double
tax as an individual now I know this
state is big on you know a lot of folks
don't want income tax in New Hampshire
don't believe in income tax but in all
honesty in escort you're actually
creating an individual income tax
because you are double double taxation
on a small business
and then taxing that individual that
owns it as he passes it through his own
business
again I explain that well any questions
feel free
thanks questions representative Platt
you were speaking at 78 RPM and I'm
trying to write it down at 34
RPM so I have a question just to follow
up explain slowly how the the S
corporation is taxed twice in New
Hampshire so s corporations the business
itself the any of the income the S
corporation makes is actually taxed they
has a New Hampshire income tax on the
profits made by the es Corp then any
money that's let's say there's money
left over that profit and it gets split
up to the equity to equity members in
the business or business owners that
money gets taxed again as a separate on
the because the business and the equity
are both passed through the owner's
income taxes so it's double
taxed in the state New
Hampshire follow up so the fix I didn't
the bill is uh right not right in front
of me so the fix is to exclude s Corps
from uh inter from interest and
dividends or what it's to to mirror what
the federal requirements are and the
other states as well where it states
that a escorp is only taxed on the
income the actual Corporation makes the
same as what an LLC would be the same as
way and because it's passed through a
personal income tax so it's to recognize
an ESC Corp as a small business and it's
not double taxed like a C corporation
is representative
Aly thank you on I think that you agreed
with him that you're talking about the
interest in dividends tax that's correct
yes which you guys have just repealed I
know I'm trying to put it back but you
guys have just repealed
it and uh what is your question my
question is
on all those other state most of those
other states uh pass through the profits
of the firm
to
on to um personal income
taxes so it does get taxed but it
sounded to me when I read this like
you're trying to say that in New
Hampshire the any profit from that
business is not
taxed how do you
differentiate the escorp profit from the
all of the people that share in
it so um so um myself owning an escorp I
actually was taxed by the state of New
Hampshire twice
uh one is on the profit that the
business made you get taxed by state of
New Hampshire and then out that profit
if I pay any of it to myself as Equity
as part of ownership of the company then
that gets that got taxed again so if you
make a distribution to yourself that's
correct then then that is
taxed under the interest in dividends
tax that's correct just just like a C
corporation correct which at this point
is is going away
but gradually I believe is so much over
so many years or something like that on
well the last yeah it's next
year so if the interest in dividends tax
is not there after next year does this
bill make any
sense if it would if it's fully
eliminated then no it would not unless
the um at some point if the interest and
dividend tax did come back then it would
be the there's still no um you're
correct if it went fully away and stayed
away then no it would not make any
difference however if there was ever a
if it was tax was ever brought back by
Equity or dividends then it would
actually um there would need to be the
separation again between small business
S Corp and C Corps
again represent
ORS thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh would you believe
that I agree with representative Aly in
the fact that I think we should pass
this bill in the event that if the indd
tax comes back we're basically coupling
this to the federal tax return if you
will and it'll work the same way so
therefore I like both of your ideas
thank
you representative
Aly
alternatively um uh the the people
trying to bring back IND which is a very
important part of our tax system on
could look
into on the exemption for the es Corps
which would require I think a certain
amount of discussion with
Dr about that your question was that a
would you believe on that's a would you
you believe thank you I don't believe in
bills for things that haven't happened
yet
representative so I I guess this is
really Dr
but I'll ask the question this way the
there is a fiscal note on this bill as
there should be and uh table
two on the the fiscal note which is
attached to the
bill uh um says that uh the Dr believes
that there will be a cumulative fiscal
impact
2026 2027 and forward that's very
significant uh 424,000 million $424
million uh so um have you looked at that
and can you uh what your view of that I
have and the question I have and this is
where represent of Aly and
representative ours ORS um actually
correct is that if if it was remain to
be able to uh that interest dividends
actually remain the same then then this
would really be no change to what's
already happening um where this would
come into effect as if they tried to
bring back the interest and dividend tax
on the ESC Corp in the future um then it
would uh from what I gather out of it
how much of this money would actually be
brought back
in thank you and I think you know rather
than pursuing this line of questioning
it would be best to get D yes I have had
a similar question any other questions
for the
representative I would hope he would
stay microphone I would St hope he would
stay to listen to Mr Wong talk to talk
about this and then make comments as
necessary okay thank you okay um seeing
no other questions thank
you and we'll invite up Keem
mangang good afternoon uh members of the
committee my name is Keen mwell tax
policy council with the Dr um I'm here
to take any questions on the bill and uh
representative Ames did you want to ask
your question
again yeah if you could explain
uh What
uh this bill
does that in your estimation will
cause this significant loss of income
that's shown in your fiscal note right
um so essentially as was explained by
the uh sponsor um the New Hampshire
treats uh es Corps uh taxes the EXs on
for business profits tax purposes at the
entity level um and then the uh the pass
through from the uh income and expense
elements that passed through from the es
crops to the owners of the ESC crops are
not tax uh for New Hampshire purposes
what is tax um for New Hampshire and
purposes is the distribution uh so if
there's any actual distribution from The
Entity level to the owners that would
potentially be subject to an indd tax
but flow throughs is a uh it's a
automatic occurrence for uh es corpse um
for federal tax purposes um the the es
crops are not taxed at the entity level
all the flow through elements are then
recorded at the owner level and they the
owners who if they are individuals and
they would file that according the with
in uh with their 1040 returns um so this
fiscal note here that shows this amount
loss here does not take into account any
kind of indd tax because we do not know
whether there's a distribution but this
is taking into account the uh the
taxpayers that file uh a DP 1220s which
is indicating that they are an escorp
and then taking that item off the uh the
the counting the calculation of the
gross business profits for for BPT
purposes and that would be the uh the
resulting loss because um this bill if
reading this bill it does not
contemplate any kind of Taxation at the
owner level for the escr
profits so then um is it true then that
if if the idd goes away then the fiscal
impact is
zero no no um if I this this fiscal yeah
this fiscal impact here does not take
into account any kind of distribution to
the indd that would be taxed at the indd
level so this is just um yeah with well
what is this tax because I thought a
distribution is then tax as a dividend
correct this is a business profits tax
calculation why would it affect the
business I'm confused now why would it
affect the business profits tax es crops
uh conducting business activities in New
Hampshire will file a business profits
tax but they would but my understanding
under this bill they would still pay the
business profits tax but they wouldn't
pay the distribution they would not pay
the business profits tax oh they ALS so
according to this bill they would not
pay the business business profits tax oh
so they wouldn't pay the business
profits tax and they wouldn't pay a
distribution the distribution would be a
different thing so if the indd is still
uh active any kind of distribution from
the escr to the individuals who are New
Hampshire residents uh would be subject
to the indd
tax okay I guess I I didn't get that
from reading the bill initially that the
There's No Business profits tax either
currently there is currently New
Hampshire treats s crops and C crops the
same so there is business profits tax at
the entity level right from my reading
of this bill this changes that treatment
uh and then allows the recognition of
the flow
through and therefore um the es crops at
the entity level will not be filing a
business profits tax return but the flow
through um but doesn't take into account
so it's saying that
to to follow the federal treatment which
is the flowr treatment so if the if the
owners are not New
Hampshire I guess I don't know how we
don't have a personal income tax um and
then I guess the uh the owners would
then need to file uh New Hampshire 1040
or something like that it's it's going
to be different from the current Uh
current
practice yes for Pres
I went from A to Z on this but yeah the
question I have I did too if it it's an
escorp I mean if this bill were to pass
under
S
Corp does the escort pay a
bet yes if um the escort would yeah pay
BPT or or bet whichever is
applicable
wait a minute if if
it if it passes if this passes this
passes oh sorry then they're not paying
any they're not paying bet not paying
BPT well this is a this is an amendment
to the BPT statute RSA
77-a there's no Amendment to the BET
statute um if
the if the
entity you know falls into the BET
filing requirement ments and then
therefore that entity would still need
to file a bet return un unless that's
also a similar Amendment for back okay
yes represent Jes I think I understand
and I think I and some others were
misreading this so so what you're saying
is
that I hope you're hearing me all right
uh that the
bill
uh
excludes at theend ESC core
level all of the flowthrough
items uh that are identified through the
federal
process uh from a BBT
tax and then there's nothing to pick it
up at the next level so it's a net loss
for the state is that right that is
correct
yeah okay well then that's a that's a
bit of a
problem yes represent elberger thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question
um there would be an impact on the IND
tax with if there is an actual
distribution there will be an indd tax
if the IND tax is still um effective and
I assume that you have not done any
analysis on the potential impact of that
no we have not because we do not know
what is the distribution all right thank
you y
okay any other
questions represent
me yeah I know I'm trying to figure out
how to phrase this um would there be a
way to rewrite this so that it was
only uh concerning the indd tax if the
IND tax came back I that does doesn't
sound to me like a workable proposition
in our legislature but that is that
waiting for saying if something else
happens then we're going to do
this
um I'm not sure that's a Dr a Dr
question does anyone have any more
questions he's the tax policy analist
well I mean you you asked him if it was
possible to to excl I mean in law we can
well if it was possible to do it as a if
this happens that happens uh in a law
and I'm not sure uh some people have
tried to do that I don't remember if any
of them ever
passed um I remember there was one time
for BPT that something to do with um I
think it was the
apportionment um that if the uh if the
revenue the state revenue was at a we
had trigger bills yes there was
something like that I remember there was
something done those yes okay representa
ORS thank you Mr chair uh would it be
possible to invite representative Jim
back to the table that's what I was
about to do but I took your question
Summers okay thank
you um yes representative
Summers thank you um so I guess the I
guess the the question is first for two
questions one is did you in was your
intention to make this bill so that S
Corp owners did not pay BPT and did not
pay the pass through or was it only the
pass through portion you it was only it
correct it was it was basically to end
up overall you end up treating and
that's what I was going to say as a
resolution to treat an es Corp like an
LLC so they're still paying taxes on
their actual business but anything they
distribute to themselves they wouldn't
be pay or be fall under the BT and so it
follows the same as what the federal
government does with es Corps as well
okay I that's what I thought was your
intention so I think then but given the
interpretation from Dr I can see how
they interpret it that way we may need
to um amend this bill to get to that
point Thank you any other questions or
clarifications represent Aly you look
like you're thinking oh yeah I am trying
to to get my head around
on how
we we could amend the indd bill to
exclude what would sound like
permissible uh amounts from from the es
corpse I UND do I think I understand the
problem I'm just not sure what what is
considered um because Fair under a
judge's
rule cuz federally um es Corps are
treated exactly like LLC Hampshire for
for New Hampshire um for New Hampshire
they're not but um on the federal side
they treated exactly like llc's and Es
Corps are basically the same and then
you have except for ES Corps have the
ability to give out to equity where
llc's
don't and and do wages as well for the
owners okay thank you I I mean we we
will have a work session on this and um
certainly if you've got some ideas on
amendment that might make that clear we
would welcome that
absolutely all
right any other uh any other questions
for
anybody okay seeing none thank you thank
you did you have something else you
wanted to say
okay
uh thank you just just one more item um
it could potentially be a constitutional
issue as well when you're carving out
the treatment of es cors versus C Corps
differently so I just want that to be
consideration interesting okay thank
you maybe it's not so simple
representative
loople if I'm getting this wrong forgive
me um is that part of the issue that if
we're trying to mirror a
federal um the Federal Way that this is
taxed is it because the the flow through
is is based on like a personal income
tax and that exists at the federal level
and not in our state or am I just
completely barking up the
rry um it is similar to that as well but
also the treatment of um the same class
of um I guess same class of property to
be taxed similarly so a C Corp versus an
S
corp um would if you're carving that out
differently then it potentially could be
treating similar classes of property
differently thank you could I I have I
have one question um so an es Corp is up
to 100
employees is my understanding or think
shareholders or or I don't think it's
employees I believe I'm sorry up I'm
sorry up to 100 oh I don't know
shareholders I I think the the uh the
requirements for an scrop is more on the
shareholders side as opposed to an
employees number of employees I believe
it's the shareholders okay and then how
about an LLC Can an LLC have um 100
owners um I I do not know the limitation
on llc's um okay I'm just trying to
think about the differences between an
es Corp and an LLC in terms of
um so ownership an LLC is uh the way of
business is organized like so the state
recognizes the LLC as the uh the
organization of a of a entity and then
the LLC can file either um as a
partnership file taxes as a partnership
or file it as a corporation and then it
files it as a corporation it can upt to
file as an escort therefore um make the
election to file as an
esort and if they file as an escorp this
is bringing it to more and then if they
follow as NES Corp does that mean now
when they do a distribution to the
partners the partners have to pay um on
the um as a dividend yes so the IND as
it is right now it is um
for Partnerships
llc's and associations that are
represented by uh non-transferable
shares they they they themselves are
subject to the in at the entity level so
if they're not represented by
transferable shares uh then uh well and
then if they're subject to the indd at
the entity level then any kind of
distribution to the members will not be
subject to indd so there won't be a
double implication of
indd um okay yeah thank you um I think
we will take more of this up in the work
session I think people are about done um
could could I just ask if we could get
on
whether what in the in the New Hampshire
law on if es Corp how how whether
there's a limitation on
employees in es
Corps and the llc's actually but I'm
pretty sure there isn't one in
llc's um or owners and or owners yeah
and what those those might
be yes sure and how you avoid double
taxation in the
llc's this I thought what you just said
something that oh in terms of the indd
indd okay sure
okay
okay thank
you
yeah all right we'll close the public
hearing on HB
1551 um so next week uh we do not have
any committee meetings scheduled I guess
we'll find out uh tomorrow evening
whether we're going to have a house
session that week or not but uh we'll
have no committee meetings next week and
um I did I don't know if it's thank you
it sounded pretty sure that we're having
a house issue really okay On
th yeah okay um but the following week
the we will have a committee meeting on
the 30th you should see it in your
emails later today the 30th and the 31st
and my goal in those two is we will
finish all the public hearings of the
bills we currently have in committee on
the 30th and 31st so then in early
February we'll start doing work sessions
and exec sessions
so
any if there's no other questions thank
you all for
coming you us
time